Sollten sie sein? Wenn du etwas hast, das du niemanden wissen willst, dann solltest du es vielleicht nicht in den ersten Platz tun. Und es ist wichtig, zum Beispiel, dass wir alle in den USA zu dem Patriot-Akt sind, ist es möglich, dass diese Information zu den Autoritäten hergestellt werden kann.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 165. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier zu einer neuen Ausgabe, wo es mal wieder, naja, wo mal wieder am Anfang nicht so richtig feststeht, wohin die Reise eigentlich genau gehen soll. Ich dachte mir mal, man müsste mal ein bisschen über Privatsphäre quatschen, was ja irgendwie in aller Munde ist und eine ganze Menge aktueller Debatten dominiert, wo aber irgendwie für meinen Geschmack die Lager ein wenig durchdrehen und wo irgendwie so ein bisschen aus dem Fokus gerät, worüber man denn eigentlich redet. Und da ich mir da auch selber manchmal ein bisschen unsicher bin und Einorderungsbedarf habe, dachte ich mir, hole ich mir mal so zwei andere Denker ins Haus, um mal so ein bisschen zu quatschen. Und ich begrüße, von links nach rechts, einerseits Christian Heller.
Hallo.
Hallo. Auch Plomplompom genannt. Ich habe eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich den Nickname zuverlässig aussprechen konnte, ohne rot zu werden, in der Angst, das falsch gemacht zu haben.
Alles gut.
Alles gut. Und ja, Michael Seemann, Michael Seemann oder auch MS Pro genannt.
Hallo.
Hallo. Du bist das erste Mal hier bei Chaosradio Express.
Genau.
Plomplompom, der war schon hier. Und zwar zwei Mal hast du hier irgendwie mit einigen Nachhall-Inhalte hinterlassen. Also die Sendung zum Retro-Futurismus habe ich nicht nur deshalb noch guten Erinnerungen, weil ich da so unglaublich müde war mit dieser Sendung und du mit Gregor irgendwie den Inhalt übernommen hast, aber auch so die Internet-Meme-Sendung war irgendwie total großartig. Wer die noch nicht gehört hat, CRE 121, Internet-Meme, wichtige Grundausbildung zum Thema Internet und CRE 6060, Retro-Futurismus, wichtige Grundausbildung zum Thema Zukunft. So, aber jetzt wollen wir ja mal so ein bisschen, ja, es geht auch so ein bisschen um die Zukunft und auch so ein bisschen um die Vergangenheit. Warum habe ich euch eigentlich hergebeten? Also, ich weiß, dass jeder von euch sich auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise natürlich einerseits mit dem Netz und der Netzkultur auseinandersetzt, andererseits aber auch so diese ganzen Debatten um Privatsphäre, glaube ich, mehr oder weniger intensiv begleitet hat. Du, Christian, hast ja sogar einen Vortrag gehalten. Wie hieß der nochmal?
Embracing post-privacy optimism towards a future where there is nothing to hide.
Ja, da bist du ganz schön ins Westenest eingedrungen, oder?
Ja, also damals, so 2008, hatte ich zumindest den Eindruck, dass es noch nicht so richtig eine Mainstream-Position ist. Jetzt auf so was wie dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress, was da der Fall war, halt eine Antidatenschutz-Position zu vertreten, weil ja doch eigentlich in dem Umfeld so eine positive Einstellung gegenüber Datenschutz und gegenüber einem gesunden Paranoia zum Schutz der eigenen Privatsphäre ja doch eher szene-typisch ist.
Und wie ist das denn so aufgenommen worden?
Also ich war eigentlich entteufelt, als ich den Vortrag erhalten habe, wie wenig Geschwimpfe ich bekommen habe. Das war alles mehr so ein, ja, kann man mal auch so sehen, Kopfnicken mit so ein paar validen Kritiken an der Argumentationskette, aber jetzt keine große Empörung zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass es dann allgemein eher ein kontroverses Thema in späterer Zeit wurde, als dann tatsächlich so die Idee, man könne auch mal gegen Privatsphäre feuern, auch so in der, sagen wir mal so ganz furchtbar identitär, in der hiesigen Netzbewegung durchaus auch etwas breiter aufgestellt war. Da hatte ich den Eindruck, wurden dann die Kämpfe auch etwas härter und man hat sich etwas mehr gegenseitig an den Kopf geworfen. Na ja, ich habe so den Eindruck, das kann man natürlich auch anders vielleicht sehen, aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass es durchaus zwei Extrempositionen gibt. Das heißt, einerseits Leute, die der Ansicht sind, dass Privatsphäre etwas sehr schützenswertes ist, dass Datenschutz etwas sehr schützenswertes ist, weil sie die individuelle Freiheit bewahren und die Menschenwürde und das deshalb es gilt alles einzusetzen, um diese Werte zu festigen und gegen Angriffe zu verteidigen und eine Gegenposition, die gerade in der Auflösung der Privatsphäre, aber auch in vielen Sachen, die eigentlich dem Datenschutz strukturell widersprechen, Potenziale sehen und die diese Potenziale stark zu machen versuchen und dass diese beiden Positionen sich dann natürlich in ihren Strategien beißen und aneinandergeraten und sich dann halt durchaus auch etwas kappeln.
Also ich habe auch irgendwie das Gefühl, dass dieser Konflikt eigentlich länger schon schwählt. Du warst für mich auch der Erste, der das irgendwie so offen ausgesprochen hat. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern an die Freiheit statt Angst-Thema. Ich weiß nicht, 2008 war das, glaube ich, noch. Da hat dann auch, ich glaube, von der hedonistischen Internationale hat er auch eine Rede gehalten, in der er dann auch anfing, so auf die ganzen Leute, die bei Facebook sind, zu schimpfen. Also das ist irgendwie, und da habe ich dann auch irgendwie gedacht, so Moment mal, was macht er denn da? Also der hat dann wirklich so gesagt, und dann die ganzen Leute, da müsst ihr euch auch selber angucken, dass ihr da irgendwie bei Twitter seid und dann bei Facebook und dass ihr da eure Sachen...
ob das so ein Monty irgendwas, der diese Rede gehalten hat, wo er explizit auch den Leuten halt vorgehalten hat, ok, ihr seid jetzt einerseits irgendwie hier, wer aber ja Datenschutz toll findet und gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung seid, aber gleichzeitig seid ihr doch dieselben Leute, die tatsächlich alles Mögliche von sich ins Netz stellen und nicht nur von sich, sondern natürlich auch von anderen und dadurch eigentlich gerade den Schutz der Privatsphäre und den Datenschutz untergraben. Und das ist natürlich, da hat er ja dann auch gar nicht so unrecht eine leicht paradoxe Position vielleicht auf den ersten Blick.
Ja klar, natürlich, das wird ja auch tatsächlich der Netzbewegung ganz oft auch so vorgeworfen, so hey, ihr gebt doch eure Daten selber preis. Und dann wird dann aber natürlich ganz eigentlich aber auch wiederum zu Recht auf diese Idee der informationellen Selbstbestimmung rekurriert und gesagt, ja, aber ich bestimme selber, was ich von mir ins Netz stelle und was von mir öffentlich ist und was nicht und so. Und darauf hat sich ja eigentlich die Netzszenen immer einigen können. Das heißt, diese Idee, dass das Subjekt selber darüber bestimmt, welche Daten jetzt in welcher Öffentlichkeit dastehen. Das ist ja das, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch so geurteilt hat. Und das war dann immer so ein bisschen dieser Rückzugsraum, auf der dann diese Widersprüchlichkeit dann doch wieder irgendwie auf so einen Nenner gebracht werden konnte. Allerdings, und das ist jetzt eben der Witz, glaube ich, kommen wir jetzt so an so eine Grenze, wo das eben nicht mehr funktioniert.
Wo die Öffentlichkeiten, die Privatsphäre eben nicht mehr so sauber trennbar sind, dass du sagen kannst, ich gewähre jetzt Leuten irgendwie, dass sie selbstbestimmt die Grenze überfreiten können, weil die Grenze nämlich gar nicht mehr so genau sichtbar ist. Und man auch nicht weiß, an welcher Stelle man sie verletzt.
Genau, das ist halt, ja genau.
Vielleicht liegt es auch so ein bisschen an einem Mangel von Definitionen, was denn nun eigentlich zur Privatsphäre gehört.
Ja, also wenn man sich das, da gibt es natürlich viele Definitionsstreitereien, aber historisch werden da so Sachen gerne reingezählt, wie beispielsweise die Familie, der häusliche Bereich. Ganz historisch gesehen kommen dann irgendwann auch so Konzepte, wie es gibt halt so das, was jetzt so dem Familienvater unterstellt ist und der ist so die einzige Schnittstelle zu einer Öffentlichkeit und alles darunter hat sich entsprechend private Regeln zu verhalten und gehört halt eben in eine eigene Welt, ein eigenes Dach, die eigenen Regeln folgt. Und dann gibt es da halt noch so die öffentliche Welt im Gegensatz, die so den Regeln der Gesellschaft folgt und wo Sachen dem öffentlichen Diskurs unterliegen, eine gewisse Transparenz haben, wo auch irgendwie die Gemeinschaft das Recht hat mitzureden, wie Leute sich beispielsweise verhalten, während halt, wenn es zum Kindererziehung in der Familie geht, so die privatistische Position halt wäre, wie ich meine Kinder erziehe, das geht halt die Öffentlichkeit eher nichts an und die kann da eben nicht mitbestimmen, beispielsweise welchen Glauben ich denen einrede. Das heißt, es gibt da so ein Bereich, so das häusliche, das domizile, das familiäre und halt auch, ich würde sagen, das ist dann eher so die neuere Entwicklung, dass man auch explizit von so einem autonomen Individuum ausgeht, was für sich einen einen Schutzbereich hat, in dem es sich halt so als Individuum entfalten kann, der dann auch Personengruppen umfasst wie halt beispielsweise Frauen und Kinder.
Aber das ist ja kinderlos. Dich tangieren diese Begriffsdefinitionen wahrscheinlich wenig, oder?
Naja, ich bin natürlich trotzdem Teil einer Familie. Das heißt, ich habe Eltern, ich bin zwar selber kinderlos. Insofern kann ich nicht der Gesellschaft den Zugriff auf ein Kind verbieten, das ich nicht habe. Aber das ist jetzt nicht mein Fall. Aber jetzt ein Fall, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass man auch den Ahnenbaum umgekehrt einen Schutz der Privatsphäre beanspruchen könnte, wäre beispielsweise, wenn man einen Elternteil hat, der schwer krank ist, meinetwegen Alzheimer hat. Und dann würde man vielleicht nicht wollen, dass die Öffentlichkeit jetzt auf diesen Elternteil Zugriff hat und diese Person irgendwie in peinliche Lagen bringt. Das heißt, man würde dann einen Schutzbereich um eine solche Person aufbauen wollen, wo man sagt, ich kann mit dieser Person umgehen, ich fühle mich dieser Person verantwortlich, ich möchte selber halt bestimmen, wo jetzt beispielsweise diese Person ihren Lebensabend verbringt, dass es nicht Aufgabe des Staates oder irgendwelcher Leute, die mir da von draußen reinreden wollen. Also in jedem Fall ist dieses Privatsphäre-Öffentlichkeits-Ding immer so eine Grenzierung zwischen einem drinnen und einem draußen. Und das drinnen gehört irgendwo zu, meistens zu einer Personenkonfiguration. Also entweder irgendwie ein Individuum oder zumindest eine Gruppe. Privatsphäre, die zwischen mehreren Individuen aufgeteilt wird, kann man auch Intimität nennen. Das heißt, die haben untereinander irgendwie einen eigenen Bereich. Dann gibt es halt das draußen und das umfasst halt die Gemeinschaft. Und darauf haben halt alle Zugriff. Und das ist halt ein sehr schön einfaches Bild, weil es halt diese klare Grenze gibt. Entweder alle haben darauf Zugriff und jeder kann davon Rechenschaft verlangen. Oder es umfasst halt nur einen klar abgegrenzten Bereich, wo man halt mehr oder weniger die Clubmitgliedschaft hat. Und darauf hat die Öffentlichkeit keinen Zugriff. Und es ist auch relativ klar strukturiert, was in diesem Bereich drin ist und was nicht in diesem Bereich drin ist.
Ja, es ist aber auch so, dass natürlich auch jetzt gar nicht die Familie braucht. Das ist ja eher so tradiert das Ding, wo dann immer ein Oberhaupt, ein Familienoberhaupt bestimmt, wo dann auch diese Grenze ist und wo welche Informationen nach außen dringen und welche nicht. Aber das lässt sich natürlich genauso gut auf unsere moderne, individualistische Gesellschaft runterbrechen, weil am Schluss ist dann eben das Individuum, das dann eben so seinen eigenen Schutzbereich und was ihn umgibt, dann entsprechend als privat definieren kann. Und das kann dann eben durchaus auch Beziehung zu anderen sein, zu Freundinnen, zu Freunden etc. Da braucht es ja die Familie eigentlich auch gar nicht. Also das heißt, wichtig ist eher, dass es sozusagen so eine Bestimmungsmacht gibt, die sich dann zwischen das öffentliche und das private stellt und diese Grenze definiert, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe gerade in dieser Google Streetview-Debatte für mich überraschend das erste Mal der Begriff Sozialsphäre auf, den ich so als Begriff vorher noch nicht gehört hatte, für den es auch zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt noch keinen Wikipedia-Eintrag gab. Trotzdem wurde ich dann bei Nachfragen darauf verwiesen, dass das sehr wohl so in der Rechtsprechung hier und da schon mal Anwendung gefunden hat. Na ja, im Prinzip so ein Zwischenfeld definiert. So dieses Hausgartenbereich, wo es zwar nicht im einigen Sinne privat ist, aber wo es sozusagen mein Soziotop in irgendeiner Form tangiert. Da bin ich dann richtig ins Grübeln gekommen, ob es denn sinnvoll ist, so einen Bereich gerade in dieser Debatte noch mal zu eröffnen.
Ich glaube, das hängt von den historischen Bedingungen ab. Bestimmt kann man von solchen Zwischenbereichen sinnvoll reden, wenn sie immer noch einigermaßen stabil definierbar sind. Also wie MS Pro, das eben Michael eben darstellte, dass es eben nicht nur die Familie sein muss, die jetzt in sich einen Bereich bildet, der in sich seinen eigenen Kommunikationsbereich hat, wo durchaus die Leute untereinander von einander wissen, sondern dass es da auch andere Bereiche geben kann, wie beispielsweise Freundeskreise, die dann natürlich auch sich teilweise überlagern können, die eine gewisse Komplexität und Auffaltung entwickeln können, die halt diese Einfachheit zwischen, es gibt nur die Privatsphäre, die sich immer weiter auf einen bestimmten Kern reduzieren lässt, der idealerweise irgendwie im Familienoberhaupt oder im Individuum liegt, und dann gibt es die Öffentlichkeit, die immer gleich das Ganze, die Gesellschaft ist, die halt darüber hinausgeht. Das heißt, dass es durchaus verschiedene Schwerpunkte geben kann, um die sich so Geheimhaltungsphären oder, sagen wir mal, Halböffentlichkeiten strukturieren können. Das ist, denke ich, von sehr viel gesellschaftlich realistischer in einer modernen Gesellschaft, dass man dann eben von solchen Zwischenbereichen redet oder von Bereichen, die eben unterschiedlich verteilt sein können. Aber ich glaube, selbst bei denen ist halt die Stabilität fragwürdig. Und je wackeliger ihre Definierbarkeit wird, die Grenzziehung, die man machen kann, um eine solche Sozialsphäre abzustecken, desto schwieriger wird es auch, die aufzubauen als schützenswerten Bereich.
Ja, das ist ja dann auch das Interessante. Also ich finde das durchaus seine Berechtigung, davon zu reden. Von der Sozialsphäre. Wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr einen Kernbereich wie die Familie haben, wo die eigentliche Kommunikation, die intime Kommunikation oder was als intime Kommunikation verstanden wird, eben innerhalb der Familienmitglieder passiert und dann sozusagen ein Repräsentant, der eine öffentliche Rolle hat und dann sozusagen die Schnittstelle zur Öffnunglichkeit bildet, wenn wir diese Sphäre auflösen und nun noch auf ein Einzelindividuen reden, dann sind das eben Einzelindividuen, die wiederum miteinander connected sind. Und dann ist diese Grenzziehung genau, löst sich auf. Und zwar in ganz verschiedene Bereiche. Und das ist ja auch das interessante und das Facebook-Problem, weil diese Sozialsphären sind ja eine Mehrzahl von Sphären. Weil man hat ja eben den Kollegenkreis, man hat die Familie, die Familie wird sozusagen einer von vielen Sozialsphären dadurch. Man hat die Familie, man hat den Freundeskreis, man hat den Kegelverein und das sind alles Sphären, die auch voneinander mehr oder weniger getrennt sind. Also ich würde sagen, dass Datenschutz, wenn man das jetzt so sagen würde, ist in der modernen Gesellschaft fast eigentlich auch die Trennung zwischen diesen Sphären aufrechtzuerhalten. Was vor Facebook sicherlich besser ging. Die Trennung unter den Sphären untereinander, genau. Nicht die Trennung, die Sphäre vor XY, das auch. Die Sphären vor XY. Wobei, vielleicht könnte man dann sozusagen sagen, die Sozialsphäre rest. Vielleicht könnte man die definieren oder so. Aber auf jeden Fall, das hat sich ja verkompliziert. Und da gibt es eben diese Halb- und Viertelöffentlichkeiten und dann auch diese Halböffentlichkeiten untereinander. Also das, was wir Privatsphäre genannt haben, was so als ein monolithischer Begriff ganz lange gelten hat, der gilt eigentlich seit der modernen Gesellschaft, seit, ich würde sagen, den 70er-Jahren nicht mehr so richtig. Weil wir haben durch den Individualismus, weil plötzlich die Sozialbeziehungen runtergebrochen wurden halt zu Beziehungen unter Individuen und nicht mehr einer Familie zu einer Gesellschaft.
Also das kann man vielleicht auch so darstellen. Der uralte Begriff der Privatsphäre ist ja der tatsächlich einer sehr festen Form, die auch über die gesamte Gesellschaft verteilt gleichförmig ist. Das heißt, es gibt halt so diese kleinste Zelle der Familie und wer dazugehört und wer nicht, das ist gesellschaftlich klar definiert. Das heißt, man kann sich darüber streiten, ob beispielsweise die Hausdienerchaft dazugehört oder nicht. Sie gehört vielleicht zum Haushalt dazu, aber sie gehört halt nicht vom Blut dazu. Das heißt, man hat relativ klare Grundlagen, wem man beispielsweise zu einer Familie zählt. Das haben wir ja heute noch, wenn beispielsweise die Frage gestellt wird, wem steht erbrechtlich etwas zu oder wer gehört jetzt durch Ehefließung dazu. Darüber wird ja auch gestritten. Aber der alte Zustand ist eigentlich, dass das eine relativ lange Zeit sehr stabil definiert ist und dass man dann halt sehr eindeutig dazugehört oder nicht. Und dass wenn ich jetzt irgendeine beliebige Person aus der Gesellschaft nehme, ich über die ziemlich eindeutig sagen kann, der gehört zu der Familie oder nicht. Und dass das eigentlich jetzt die relevante Grenzziehung ist. Das heißt, entweder ich gehöre in diesen kleinen Bereich der Privatsphäre hinein oder ich habe zu den anderen Leuten nur ein Verhältnis über die Öffentlichkeit. Und dann unterliegt das auch nicht in den Bedingungen der Privatsphäre. Und dann wird das halt dann irgendwann komplizierter, wenn tatsächlich es eine größere Freiheit der Formen und der Zuordnungen gibt. Wenn halt die Familie eben nicht nur das einzige Club ist, zu dem ich gehören kann. Oder die einzige Hierarchie, in die ich eingepasst werde. Das heißt, wenn beispielsweise die Gesellschaft mehr und mehr sich für die, sagen wir das jetzt mal so kapitalistisch, für die Ausbeutung der Individuen interessiert, losgelöst von jetzt größeren Gemeinschaften, wie beispielsweise der Familie, sie also herauslösen möchte, atomisieren möchte und in neue Verhältnisse zueinander setzen möchte. Dann haben wir halt eine Situation, in der eigentlich diese alte Gruppenform nicht mehr so viele Ansprüche darauf hat, um sich herum einen Gartenzaun abzustecken und zu sagen, für alles in dieser, innerhalb dieses Gartenzauns gelten gesonderte Regeln, für alles außerhalb dieses Gartenzauns gelten andere Regeln. Sondern dann habe ich ja plötzlich viele Gärten, die einander überlagern müssen, wo dann auch teilweise definiert werden muss an einer bestimmten Stelle, zu welchem Garten und dessen Regeln gehört denn jetzt eine bestimmte Situation. Also beispielsweise ist das jetzt eine familienrechtliche oder arbeitsrechtliche Frage. Und je weiter diese Atomisierung der einzelnen Bestandteile getrieben wird, desto mehr habe ich eigentlich Verwirrung, in welchem Club denn jetzt eigentlich irgendein Körper in einer gegebenen Situation gehört. Und das führt natürlich auch dazu, wenn jetzt ein Körper in mehreren Situationen ist und natürlich in diesen auch Informationen weiterträgt, dann kann ich durchaus plötzlich aus einer Privatsphäre eines solchen Gartens etwas in die Privatsphäre aus einem anderen Garten tragen. Und je mehr solche Überlagerungen gibt es, desto mehr gibt es halt diese Informationsleaks von dem einen in das andere. Und wenn halt überhaupt keine Übersichtlichkeit mehr besteht, wer denn jetzt unter welchen Bedingungen in welchen Garten eingegrenzt werden kann, dann habe ich eigentlich keine Möglichkeit mehr, klare Informationsflussregeln zu definieren. Das gehört jetzt alles nur in den Bereich und das gehört jetzt alles nur in den Bereich, weil halt plötzlich mein Arbeitgeber irgendwie jemanden kennt, mit dem ich zur Schule gegangen bin, der wiederum weiß, mit wem ich im Bowling-Club bin. Und diese Person im Bowling-Club wiederum meintet, der Schwager ist von so und so, die dann wiederum mal eine Beziehung mit meinem Arbeitgeber hatte. Und auf diese Weise gibt es halt sehr viel komplexe soziale Zusammenhänge, die auch nicht mehr einfach hierarchisch strukturiert werden können, sondern wo es halt ein Hin und Her und ein Auf und Ab ist. Und dementsprechend verhalten sich dann auch die Informationen, die fließen können.
Ja, ich meine, so dieser Datenschutz, du hast, Michael, du hast vorhin gesagt, seit den 70er Jahren ändert sich das. Finde ich interessant, dass du das in den 70er Jahren verortest.
Es ändert sich dauernd, also natürlich, aber diese Individualisierung darauf wollte ich hinaus.
Aber ist diese Individualisierung nicht vor allem auch eine Folge der Änderung des Telekommunikationsverhaltens? Also gut, ich will jetzt nicht streiten, ob das jetzt besser in den 70er oder 80er Jahren angelegt ist. Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist, was wir auf jeden Fall sehen, ist ja auch eine ganz klar vom CCC, nicht nur vom CCC, aber von dem CCC mit geprägte Debatte, die eigentlich einen Großteil ihrer Grundlage in so einem klassischen, der Staat und das Individuum Situation findet. Also immer so ein bisschen mit dem Schreckgespenst der Nazis und ihrer automatisierten Judenerfassung wurde halt immer schnell abgeleitet, dass der Bürger sozusagen vor dem Zugriff des Staates weitgehend geschützt werden muss. Und daraus leitet sich halt einerseits dieser Datenschutz ab und diese Selbstbestimmung. Man kann nicht einfach jetzt von mir die Informationen so sammeln und einsammeln und weiterverarbeiten und weiterverteilen, wie man möchte, um mich eben konkret zu schützen.
Ich glaube, da muss man auch erstmal differenzieren. Wir haben jetzt gerade über Privatsphäre gesprochen und diese Privatsphäre als etwas sehr Komplexes dargestellt. Das ist ja auch richtig. Aber tatsächlich der Begriff Datenschutz, der kommt ursprünglich und eigentlich fast ausschließlich tatsächlich als ein Abwehrrecht gegen den Staat. Und das ist schon richtig. Das ist auch so ein bisschen aus der Erfahrung der Nazizeit, wo die Nazis durchaus eine der, sage ich mal, sehr prominent darin waren, vom staatlich erfassten Daten dafür zu nutzen, um z.B. Juden auszusortieren und sie in die Lager zu schicken. Und die halt durchaus eine für ihre Zeit sehr fortgeschrittene Datenverarbeitung hatten. Also damals mit diesen Lochkarten. Und das ist ja immer noch irgendwie so in den Köpfen drin. Und das ist ja auch richtig. Und es gibt eben diesen Datenschutz, der ist einerseits daraus entstanden und eigentlich speist er sich immer noch hauptsächlich als Abfrecht gegen den Staat, was eine gewisse Berechtigung hat. Also weil der Staat ist nun mal die Institution, der unsere gesamte Gewalt, der das gesamte Volk, ihre Gewalt übertragen hat. Sie haben das Gewaltmonopol. Sie dürfen Druck und alles Mögliche ausüben, um einzelne Individuen in bestimmte Spuren zu bringen oder nicht. Und dementsprechend ist es, glaube ich, schon ganz sinnvoll, dort eben ein sehr, sehr waches Auge drauf zu haben, was der Staat mit den Daten zum Beispiel macht. Das ist aber jetzt eine relativ neue Entwicklung. Und das finde ich ganz interessant, dass eigentlich mehr oder weniger die gleiche Argumentation jetzt gegenüber privatwirtschaftlichen Firmen passiert. Ich glaube, das ging irgendwie in den 90ern erst los, ehrlich gesagt. Soweit ich das weiß. Dass plötzlich das gleiche Abwehrrecht jetzt gegen privatwirtschaftliche Firmen in Stellung gebracht wird. Und zum Beispiel dieses Recht der informationellen Selbstbestimmung, die ja aus der Volkszählungsurteil 87 herausgeleitet wurde, die wird jetzt plötzlich gegen Firmen in Stellung gebracht. Das ist irgendwie auch etwas Neues. Ich habe letztens auch einen interessanten Artikel von Heribert Prantl gelesen, wo er tatsächlich darlegen will, warum es noch viel wichtiger ist, dieses informationelle Selbstbestimmungsrecht gegenüber den Konzernen noch mehr in Stellung zu bringen, als gegenüber dem Staat Weil. Und so argumentiert er, weil wir gegen die Firmen eben keinerlei demokratische Rechtsmittel besitzen. Vor allem nicht in den ausländischen Firmen. Gegenüber dem Staat allerdings doch. Wobei er dann komplett unter den Tisch fallen lässt, dass es eben genau dieses Gewaltmonopol gibt und dass Google mich nicht nachts aus meinem Haus holen kann.
Du wirst noch nicht.
Ja, noch nicht.
Es ist ja eigentlich eine plausible Entwicklung, wenn man dann irgendwann anerkennt, okay, wir haben jetzt nicht mehr das dritte Reich, sondern wir haben einen Staat, der doch relativ menschenfreundlich ist und relativ demokratisch kontrolliert. Jetzt haben wir natürlich ein Abwehrrecht, was auch irgendwie Teil dieses demokratisch Kontrollierseins zu sein beansprucht. Und jetzt haben wir aber den Staat gar nicht mehr so sehr als Bedrohung. Dadurch, dass der Staat sozusagen als die Hauptbedrohung gegenüber uns schrumpft, sehen wir dann hinter dem Staat halt andere Körper, die im früheren Fall nicht so sehr eine Bedrohung waren. Die haben jetzt halt relativ ein höheres Bedrohungspotenzial uns gegenüber vielleicht als der Staat, weil es halt große, machtvolle Corporations sind, die international agieren und so weiter, während der Staat ja eigentlich nur so ein kleines, so ein kleiner Raum ist, den wir uns relativ gut selbst gestalten können und der auch nicht mehr so viel Gewaltpotenzial gegen uns hat, wie beispielsweise, wenn Google fähig ist, über seine Steuerung der Informationswelt Existenzen zu vernichten, indem es sie beispielsweise ausblendet oder Google-Bomben halt ermöglicht.
Aber ich glaube, es ist schon noch einfacher für den Staat, deine Existenz zu vernichten als für Google.
Nicht, dass Google da jetzt keine Ahnung haben kann.
Das würde ich persönlich auch so sehen, aber ich glaube, man kann da durchaus ein Argumentationsmuster aufbauen, was halt in die Richtung geht. Der Staat ist jetzt nicht mehr so sehr die Bedrohung und dadurch, dass er als Bedrohung schrumpft, können wir jetzt die Futzrechte, die wir gegenüber Sachen haben, die gegenüber uns als Individuum vielleicht machtvoller sind, als wir selbst als Individuum es ihm gegenüber sind, halt gegenüber anderen Playern ins Spiel bringen, die vielleicht nicht so gefährlich sind, wie jetzt meinetwegen das Dritte Reich, aber doch, also selbst wenn sie weniger gefährlich sind, gefahren sind sie dann vielleicht, sagen wir wissen gerade doch noch für uns.
Aber ich meine so Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das sind ja nun schon relativ massive Maßnahmen, um die sozusagen explizit die Privatsphäre im Sinne von meine private Kommunikation, die das betreffen. Also warum meinst du, dass dann auf einmal der Staat jetzt nicht mehr so das bedrohliche Element ist im Vergleich zu den Firmen?
Achso, das ist halt die Frage der Gefährlichkeit des Staates. Also wenn wir uns zur Dritten Reich anschauen, das Dritte Reich war ja nicht nur gefährlich, weil sie halt Daten gesammelt haben, sondern sie haben ja auch konkret tatsächlich Menschen umgebracht und Lage gebaut und dergleichen. Das heißt, sie hatten ein ganzes Gewaltinstrumentarium, was diese Daten halt umgewandelt hat in Gewalt gegen Einzelne. Während zumindest so nach einer relativ, sagen wir mal, denke ich, weit verbreiteten Ansicht, wäre er heutzutage in einem vergleichsweise freiheitlichen Staat leben, der dem Individuum im Allgemeinen weniger Faden zufügt, als das Dritte Reich ist, der es mit seinen Bürgern oder vielleicht sogar mit seinen Nichtbürgern getan hat.
Das mag er sein, aber man muss ja jetzt nicht viele Tagesreisen unternehmen, um in Länder zu fahren, in denen das sich nicht mehr unbedingt genauso verhält. Und die Debatte jetzt sozusagen nicht nur jetzt auf die Situation Deutschland haben wollen, sondern schon als grundsätzliche Betrachtung, wie man denn damit sozusagen umgehen sollte. Und es ist immer ein Staat vorstellbar, der dieses Missbrauchspotenzial mal wieder für sich urbar macht, auch wenn es vielleicht derzeit nicht unbedingt danach aussieht, dass es around the corner ist.
Jaja, also ich vertrete jetzt quasi eine Position, die eigentlich nicht die ist, die ich normalerweise vertrete, aber ich versuche halt mich halt in so beispielsweise ein Argument pro Datenschutz hinein zu versetzen. Dann könnte ich nämlich tatsächlich sagen, Datenschutz ist eine der Sachen, die diesen Zustand aufrecht erhält, dass der Staat, in dem wir derzeit leben, uns halt weniger kann, als das jetzt meinetwegen der Iran kann. Ich persönlich glaube, dass es auch an sehr vielen anderen Faktoren liegt und eben Datenschutz nicht diese Bedeutung hat für diesen Schutz gegenüber einem Staat, der zu machtvoll wird, wie das halt viele Datenschützer behaupten, weil ich nämlich durchaus glaube, dass beispielsweise das Dritte Reich nicht nur das Dritte Reich war, weil es jetzt irgendwie Daten gesammelt hat, sondern eben auch sehr viel konkretere Gewaltmechanismen in der Hand hatte. Aber wir haben natürlich einen ganzen Apparat von Rechten gegenüber dem Staat beispielsweise, die verhindern sollen, dass der Staat uns gegenüber zu mächtig wird. Und der Datenschutz wird gemeinhin als eines dieser Rechte, dieses Privilegien gegenüber dem Staat in Stellung gebracht in der Diskussion. Insofern kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass man sagen kann, wir haben jetzt durchaus auch Erfolg damit, dass wir dieses Instrument haben. Und wenn wir es nicht hätten, dann wäre der Staat sich vielleicht mehr gegenüber uns erlauben.
Also ich würde ja fast sogar die Gegenposition dazu einnehmen und sagen, dass tatsächlich eine Demokratie, wenn wir das jetzt als die Form von Staat nehmen, die eben genau solche, die einem Nationalsozialismus gegenübersteht, wenn wir das als Grundlage nehmen, dass eine Demokratie gerade im Gegenteil daraus lebt, dass es Leute gibt, die ganz öffentlich zum Beispiel Partei ergreifen, die ganz öffentlich politisch reden, die sich öffentlich machen. Ich glaube sogar, dass ein repräsentatives Regime in einer Gesellschaft, in der alle Leute sozusagen sich abkapseln voneinander und ihre Mauern hochbauen gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit, dass in so einer Situation ein totalitäres Regime viel eher möglich ist, als in einer offenen und öffentlichen Gesellschaft.
Das ist halt so, wenn du die öffentliche Sache, die Republik, alten Rom, geht dann halt in dem Moment unter, sobald sich die Leute immer weniger dafür interessieren, jetzt öffentliche Personen zu sein, sondern mehr und mehr ihre privaten Machtbereiche halt bauen und da halt ihr Leben führen. Und sowas wie öffentliche Institutionen, öffentliche Streitgespräche, das gemeinsame Bauen an einer öffentlichen Sphäre und da möglichst viel von sich hineingeben, das bröckelt dann halt weg, wenn die Leute sich immer mehr ins Private zurückziehen. Und das wäre dann deshalb eine antidemokratische Tendenz.
Ja, das ist eben auch so Hannah Arendt. Also das ist übrigens, glaube ich, ein sehr, sehr guter Buchtyp dafür. Hannah Arendt, Vita Activa, die hat genau den Bereich des Öffentlichen genauso beschrieben als den Bereich der politischen Handlung. Den Bereich, wo das Individuum eben aus dem Privaten heraustritt und in die Öffentlichkeit geht, um sich auch politisch zu engagieren. So aus dem Gedanken der griechischen Polle ist heraus. Und eben genau, dass sich eben, und das ist ein sehr, sehr demokratisches Verständnis von Öffentlichkeit und Privatheit, das Hannah Arendt da hat. Und ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, dass in Deutschland gerade dieser Öffentlichkeitsdiskurs ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist. Und dass es da überhaupt kein richtiges Gespür für gibt, dass eben eine demokratische Öffentlichkeit etwas ganz Wichtiges ist für die Demokratie. Und eben nicht, und der Datenschutz da, also ein zu krasses Datenschutzverständnis und ein zu krasses Privatsphärenverständnis, dem entgegensteht eigentlich. Und zwar eben einer durchaus partizipativen, emazipativen Demokratie.
Das ist ja auch durchaus ein plausibles Misstrauen fast gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit. Also wenn wir die Privateit als Schutzraum gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit in Stellung bringen wollen, dann ja unter anderem deshalb, weil wir befürchten, dass die Öffentlichkeit halt etwas Repressives ist. Wenn ich mich nackt in die Öffentlichkeit werfe, dann wird die Öffentlichkeit auf mich einhacken und mich zurechtformen und mich in Konformismus drängen. Und die Privatsphäre ist dann halt der Raum, in dem allein ich ich sein kann, weil da eben die Öffentlichkeit mit all ihren Messern und Druckinstrumenten usw. mir nichts kann. Und wenn wir jetzt die Öffentlichkeit als einen Ort sehen, der primär ein Repressiver ist, dann müssen wir natürlich die Privatsphäre gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit stärken. Und wir können durchaus auch zu einer solchen Annahme gelangen, wenn wir beispielsweise jetzt eine bestimmte Deutung der deutschen Geschichte vornehmen. Wenn wir beispielsweise sagen, ja, aber das deutsche Volk und dessen Öffentlichkeit und dessen Demokratie, das hat ja zu dem Dritten Reich geführt. Und das heißt, wir können durchaus nicht diesem öffentlichen Bereich vertrauen. Wenn wir halt zu viel diesen öffentlichen Bereich öffnen, dann führt das nur dazu, dass dieser öffentliche Bereich die Menschen halt kaputt macht. Deshalb müssen wir private Schutzbereiche aufbauen, in die sich die Menschen zurückziehen können, damit sie sich schützen können vor der Gesellschaft und vor dem Staat.
Das ist ja natürlich jetzt interessanter Widerspruch. Auf der einen Seite sind wir jetzt an so einem Punkt, wir brauchen die Privatheit als Schutz gegen Überwachung und gegen den Staatsmissbrauch. Das ist die eine Argumentation. Auf der anderen Seite so die Forderung, wir brauchen eine maximale Öffentlichkeit aus der Gesellschaft heraus und sozusagen die Notwendigkeit, dass die Leute sich nicht zu sehr in ihrer Burg-Privatsphäre verstecken, als Schutz vor gesellschaftlichem Untergang. Weil sonst sich das nicht weiterentwickeln kann. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wo du da sozusagen die Bedrohung siehst, wenn es einen Mangel an Öffentlichkeit gibt.
Also der Mangel an Öffentlichkeit hat natürlich zufolge, dass eine Minderheit relativ mit entsprechend lautem Auftreten das relativ schnell an sich reißen kann, was man den öffentlichen Diskurs nennt. Weil wenn wenig Leute mitmachen, das ist ja so wie in einer kleinen Partei, mit einer großen Gruppe einzutreten, dann hat man den schnell gekapert. Und wenn es eben dann keine Institutionen gibt, und Institutionen auch verstanden als durchaus Menschen, die als Intellektuelle oder als öffentliche Person halt bestimmte Meinungen vertreten, also wenn es halt sozusagen keinen großen und breiten demokratischen Diskurs gibt, dann kann man eben diesen kleinen Restdiskurs, der noch relativ schnell an sich reißen. Und kann dementsprechend ja dann durchaus so sein Ding machen. Und das ist so die Gefahr, die ich da vor allem sehe.
Aber ich glaube, es geht ja auch nicht nur darum, jetzt dafür zu streiten, dass jetzt die Öffentlichkeit das Gute ist, was wir verteidigen wollen und notfalls auch auf Kosten der Privatsphäre. Michael, wenn ich deine Texte so lese, wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, geht es ja auch beispielsweise darum, dass wir eben nicht mehr jetzt diesen einen Monolithen haben, der einen gemeinsamen Öffentlichkeit, die für alle gilt und Regeln für alle aufstellt und für alle irgendwie dieselben Begriffsdefinitionen trifft. Sondern dass ja auch gerade in der Welt von Facebook und jeder breitet irgendwie seine eigenen persönlichen Dinge aus und setzt ihn in Beziehung zu den persönlichen Dingen anderer ja durchaus so eine Fragmentierung der Gesellschaft aufbauen, die eigentlich die eine gemeinsame Öffentlichkeit in ihrem Wert auch reduziert. Das heißt eigentlich ist es nicht einfach nur so ein, wir haben jetzt hier, wir wollen jetzt quasi eine neue große Weltgesellschaft, in die jetzt alle halt ihre privaten kleinen Dinge, also für die alle ihre kleinen privaten Dinge aufgeben sollen, damit sie jetzt alle teilhaben am selben großen Körper und System. Sondern es geht ja tatsächlich auch darum, man könnte fast sagen, neue Sozialsphären zu faffen, die eben nicht einfach dann halt konsequent sich vereinigen zu einer neuen Gesamtöffentlichkeit.
Ja, das ist durchaus, aber das ist ein bisschen getragen durch die, ja wirklich sagen, neuen Umstände, durch die neuen Medien. Also da ist noch ein bisschen so ein Schritt hin. Ich würde das mal so Öffentlichkeit 2.0 mal irgendwie so vorsichtig erst mal labeln. Das ist etwas, woran ich gerade arbeite eigentlich. Das ist noch ein bisschen Arbeit eigentlich, wobei ich dann auf meinem privaten Blog immer ein bisschen darin rumblogge. Aber auf jeden Fall, nee, das ist schon richtig. Aber dafür muss man vielleicht auch erst einmal vorher diese Öffentlichkeit nehmen und diesen Begriff von öffentlich, wie wir ihn kennen und wie er bei Hannah Arendt definiert ist, und erst einmal abgleichen mit den entsprechenden Veränderungen, die wir durch das Internet durchgemacht haben. Und das ist vielleicht erst mal, glaube ich, das Wichtige. Da bin ich seit, weiß ich nicht, einem halben Jahr oder so dabei, halt diesen Begriff des Kontrollverlustes als so einen allgemeinen Begriff zu definieren und für mich klarzustellen, der eine ganze Menge von Phänomenen irgendwie mehr oder weniger erklären kann oder versucht zu erklären, die wir eben durchmachen in diesen digitalen Zeiten. Und das ist eben so ein bisschen die Grundthese, dass wir durch immer neue und immer bessere Datenverarbeitungstechniken, die sich ja sehr, sehr beschleunigt immer wieder neu einstellen, ja ein bisschen darüber die Kontrolle auch verlieren, was genau die einzelnen Daten, die wir sozusagen preisgeben, über uns noch erzählen. Also das ist das klassische Beispiel, dass ich zum Beispiel jetzt twittere, dass ich mit Christian hier zusammensitze, aber niemand weiß wo, ja. Aber dann mich gleichzeitig bei Foursquare einchecke und jemand, der mich eben bei Twitter followt und bei Foursquare, sieht dann eben über Foursquare, wo auch Christian ist. Und plötzlich ist Christians Aufenthaltsort preisgegeben, ohne dass halt irgendwie, also man muss halt mittlerweile schon über 8 Ecken denken können, um halt tatsächlich, also wie so ein Schachspieler, muss man halt schon über mehrere Züge hinweg denken, um überhaupt noch irgendwie, ja, denken, genau, eben diese informationelle Selbstbestimmung selber ausfüllen zu können. Das ist jetzt ein sehr plakatives und sehr einfaches Beispiel, aber es geht natürlich viel, viel krasser noch, wenn man eben diese großen Datenbanken nimmt, die sie die entsprechenden Data-Mining-Center so haben und was die dort alles durch Data-Crunching und so weiter und so fort über einzelne Personen und deren Relationen herausfinden. Das übersteigt mittlerweile durchaus teilweise unsere Vorstellungskraft.
Das verstärkt sich ja auch. Das heißt, je mehr ich weiß, desto mehr Hebel, also die mehr Information ich über Leute habe, desto mehr Hebel habe ich zugleich, um neue Informationen über sie zu erzeugen. Und das heißt, wir haben da so selbstverstärkende Tendenzen, dass man halt immer mehr eigentlich aus immer weniger konkreten einzelnen Informationen über Leute herausbekommen kann.
Aber trotzdem, also ich meine, ich bin ja nun, ich zum Beispiel lebe ja auch, vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen darüber reden, wie wir das so selber so handhaben. Ich zwangsläufig jetzt durch diesen Podcast, aber auch vorher, sagen wir mal, im Rahmen der Tätigkeiten im Club, habe immer schon so ein Teil öffentliches Leben geführt, ohne es jetzt total übertreiben zu wollen und zu müssen. Aber auch immer so eine gewisse Teilöffentlichkeit in Kauf genommen. Und trotzdem erschauere ich und bin auch wirklich jetzt definitiv nicht so vollverspannt, was so jetzt Datenschutz betrifft, habe allerdings auch gerade, was jetzt den familiären Kontext betrifft, sehr wohl dann auch eine gewisse Vorstellung von Privatsphäre. Ich verorte bei mir da ganz klar einen schützenswerten Bereich, auch wenn ich jetzt nicht sagen würde, alles, was ich tue und treibe, gehört dazu. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut getrennt. Wohl wissend, dass es natürlich da so einen Überlappungsbereich gibt, in dem es echt schwierig ist. Und auch Teile meiner, wie soll ich sagen, sozialen Aktivität in öffentlichen Momenten, wenn ich jetzt auf eine Konferenz gehe und da irgendwo im Gang stehe und ich unterhalte mich halt mit irgendeiner Person und ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein sehr informelles Gespräch, was ich in dem Moment gerne führe, wo ich interessante Informationen bekomme, wo ich aber nicht gleich auf Twitter losschreie, ja, ich habe mich hier mit XY unterhalten und geile Background-Infos bekomme, weil das wäre dann einfach mal extrem kontraproduktiv. Aber dann erschauert es mich halt so ein bisschen, wenn ich dann so auf Facebook so eine Mail kriege, ja, jemand hat dich auf einem Foto identifiziert. Das ist, glaube ich, so die Mail, die einzige, die mir wirklich so ein bisschen immer Respekt abnötigt, weil ich mir denke so, oh weia, jetzt hat mich da einfach einer in dieser Situation fotografiert und da entsteht jetzt so ein Datensatz, den ich so gerne nicht gesehen hätte. Ich weiß, dass ich das nicht, ja, Kontrollverlust, gutes Thema, ich weiß, dass ich das in dem Moment nicht habe verhindern können, allein ob der Realitäten, trotzdem ist das eben genau so dieser Moment, wo man so ein bisschen in Schlackern kommt. Und ich glaube, aus solchen Momenten heraus ziehen viele Leute dann aus eine gewisse Unsicherheit bis hin eben auch zur Unterstützung von radikaleren Positionen.
Ja, also bei Facebook kannst du ja auch wieder dieses Tag wieder entfernen, als wenn du als derjenige getaggt bist, kannst du das wieder entfernen.
Dafür musst du dich aber erstmal als derjenige identifizieren.
Ja, bzw. musst du dich einloggen. Du kriegst ja die Mail schon, weil du identifiziert bist. Also ich finde das interessant, also wenn dann erst, ich glaube jetzt Apple hat jetzt gerade diese Firma gekauft, die, das müsstest du bestimmt wissen, mit der Gesichtserkennung, genau. Also die ist ja noch viel, viel weiter als das, was wir jetzt bei iPhoto schon kennen und solche Sachen. Und wenn wir dann erst einmal irgendwie so etwas in einem Google-Algorithmus hatten, dann wird Google dir bestimmt nicht jedes Mal eine Mail schicken, wenn sie dich identifiziert haben. Und ich glaube, das wird nochmal sehr lustig werden. Also ich glaube, wir machen uns da noch gar keine Vorstellung. Also die Idee ist ja einfach die, dass Daten, die sind verknüpftbar. Und sie bleiben verknüpftbar. Das ist das Interessante. Also das, was wir, wenn wir uns heute angucken, was heute möglich ist an Verknüpfung, dann haben wir noch immer noch keine Vorstellung, was in zwei Jahren möglich ist. Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, diese Daten, die sind nicht tot. Die sind eben lebendig. Und die sind morgen lebendiger als heute. Und übermorgen noch lebendiger. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Kontrollverlust-These.
Also ich meine, was machst du aus dieser These, dass Kontrollverlust stattfindet oder dass Kontrollverlust gut ist? Oder Kontrollverlust ist die unklare Bedrohung?
Ja, also das ist erstmal die These, dass es so ist. Und das ist zum ersten ist das erstmal ein Angriff auf durchaus das Konzept der informationellen Selbstbestimmung an sich. Also ich hab übrigens Plom's These vom Post-Privacy, hab ich sehr früh gehört und ich war immer nicht einverstanden, weil ich hab mich auch immer darauf zurückbezogen, aber nein. Ja, Öffentlichkeit, super und so. Aber da muss doch die Grenze genau dort sein, wo ich das selber bestimme. Wo ich derjenige bin, der sagt, wie viel Freiheit und wie viel öffentlich ist und wie viel privat. Aber wenn man sich das eben genau besieht, dann sind wir gerade momentan ziemlich genau dabei an dieser Grenze, wo wir uns diese alle Kontrollmönchern, in dieser Hinsicht durchaus aus den Lappen gehen.
Also die notwendige Unsicherheit wächst halt.
Ich meine, die haben wir ja jetzt so noch nicht genannt. Kannst du die vielleicht mal bringen? Also wir reden jetzt von diesem Vortrag, den du vorhin schon erwähnt hast.
Genau. Es ist eigentlich weniger ein großes Argument. Es sind halt verschiedene kleine Thesen, die halt miteinander korrelieren. Also beispielsweise eine Kritik der Privatsphäre einerseits entlang solcher Linien, wie wir sie vorhin skizziert haben. Man kann eben nicht sagen, Privatsphäre ist jetzt das Gute und Öffentlichkeit ist jetzt der Flechte, sondern es gibt durchaus Sachen, die dafür sprechen, Sachen von der Privatsphäre abzuschneiden und in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, weil Öffentlichkeit durchaus etwas ist, was empowern kann, während Privatsphäre durchaus etwas ist, was isolieren kann. Das ist auch so eine alte Kritik. So an der Privatsphäre ist beispielsweise eine feministische Kritik, dass Privatsphäre ganz gerne auch das ist, wo man halt die Frau reinverbannt und wo sie dann irgendwie dem Familienmann ausgeliefert ist, der sie dann beispielsweise mit häuslicher Gewalt traktieren kann, ohne dass es die Gesellschaft interessiert. Denn das ist ein privates Problem, ob er jetzt die Frau schlägt oder sie in der Ehe vergewaltigt. Während dann halt so das Herausgehen in die Öffentlichkeit, dass es dann halt so Anknüpfungspunkte finden, dass sich organisieren können, dass Politische handeln. Das heißt, dass es irgendwie einen politischen Wert für Öffentlichkeit gegenüber Privatsphäre gibt. Dass gleichzeitig es halt gewissermaßen diese Form von Kontrollverlust gibt, die MS-Pro aufgezeichnet hat, die es halt schwierig macht, überhaupt noch dieses Strukturaufrecht zu erhalten, die uns eigentlich nötigt, uns überhaupt in der Öffentlichkeit mehr zu orientieren. Dass wir uns beispielsweise unsere Freiheitswerte weniger und weniger auf irgendeine Sicherheit aufbauen können, die halt wegbröckelt, weil es halt, und das ist jetzt so eine etwas fatalistisch klingende These, weil halt dieser Kontrollverlust unaufhaltsam sei, dass wir stattdessen Methoden entwickeln müssen, uns unsere Freiheit oder unsere Macht gegenüber, beispielsweise so etwas wie dem Staat, zu sichern, die nicht auf Privatsphäre aufbauen, sondern beispielsweise darauf, wie wir uns besser in der Öffentlichkeit verknüpfen können, dass es beispielsweise, vielleicht wenn es unmöglich wird, zu verhindern, dass der Staat oder andere Machtfaktoren mehr über uns wissen, dass wir dann eigentlich dieses Machtungleichgewicht nur konfrontieren können, indem wir selber auch mehr Wissen über alles sammeln, dass wir beispielsweise fordern, dass es eben nicht nur eine Pyramide gibt, die von oben nach unten alles überwacht, sondern die halt auch von unten nach oben zurückgeblickt werden kann, dass wir gleichzeitig auch darauf schauen, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich das, Was uns jetzt irgendwie einengt, wenn jemand etwas über uns weiß, also beispielsweise uns irgendeine bestimmte Identität verleiht, dadurch, dass er jetzt Daten über uns sammelt. Also beispielsweise Rastafahndung ist ja im Grunde genommen, beispielsweise wir wollen eigentlich die Identität eines Terroristen rausfinden oder eines Terror verdächtigen und sammeln deshalb Daten und korrelieren jetzt diese Daten auf eine bestimmte Weise. Und alle Leute, die jetzt unter ein bestimmtes Datenmuster fallen, dem geben wir jetzt eine bestimmte Identität, die wir anders behandeln als andere Menschen. Das heißt, die verdächtigen wir, die sperren wir ein, den machen wir das Leben schwer. Wie kann ich mich dagegen wehren, eine solche mich unterdrückende Identität zugewiesen zu bekommen? Und ist das tatsächlich nur daran gekoppelt, dass ein Wissen über mich vorhanden ist? Oder ist das nicht vielleicht auch daran gekoppelt, dass wir beispielsweise entsprechend bestimmter kultureller und sozialer Normen entscheiden, dass, was weiß ich, ich meine, wegen Leute, die eine bestimmte Hautfarbe sind, gefährlicher sind als andere Menschen? Sollte man da nicht eher diese Norm angreifen, anstatt dass das Wissen darüber gesammelt werden kann, wer diese Hautfarbe hat? Das waren so die Thesen.
Okay, das ist alles noch sehr theoretisch. Vielleicht mal auf das eine oder andere eingehen. Also mit diesem Umdrehen der Überwachungspyramide. Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Ich meine, was ist jetzt so? Der Staat hat überall Kameras in den Straßen und irgendwo sitzen irgendwelche Leute in den Kellern und schauen sich das an. Wobei es wahrscheinlich eher Festplatten sind, die sich das anschauen. Aber das ist ja so das Bild. Was heißt dann Umdrehen? Heißt das, dass dann sozusagen die Überwachungsbilder auch gleich im Fernsehen gepostet werden sollen? So wie das mal diese schöne Arte, diese gefakte Arte-Dokumentation über Island, glaube ich, mal gebracht hat?
Ja, das ist eine der Taktiken, die da vorgeschlagen wird. Also dazu muss ich kurz sagen, dieses mit dem Umdrehen der Überwachungsanordnung und dieses Einfordern, dass es halt eine allgemeine Transparenz gibt und nicht nur eine Transparenz uns gegenüber dem Staat, sondern auch umgekehrt. Das wurde sehr breit erörtert, beispielsweise von dem von dem Autor David Brin in seinem Buch The Transparent Society, die Transparente Gesellschaft, wird dann halt an sehr vielen Szenarien abgearbeitet, wie sowas aussehen könnte. Also eben beispielsweise Open the Camera Feeds, also dass wir tatsächlich Zugriff haben auf die Überwachung im Sinne von, wir können auch reinschauen. Das an sich ist aber natürlich noch ein relativ geringer Hebel, denn okay, dann kann ich vielleicht sehen, dass mein Nachbar irgendwas Böses macht, aber das verhindert nicht, dass ich Einfluss darauf haben kann, dass die Polizei kommt und den Nachbar dafür bestraft. Das heißt, ich bräuchte auch eigentlich eine Kamera, die sich auf die Polizei richtet, eine Kamera, die in dem Raum ist, wo die Leute sitzen und überwachen und dann entscheiden, wer beispielsweise deshalb gegängelt wird, wo ich dann beispielsweise auch sehen kann, okay, die Leute, die da überwachen, die ahnten vielleicht das Stärke als das andere. Das heißt, im Grunde genommen muss eigentlich die Gegenüberwachung sich vor allem auf die Macht richten, die überwacht und nicht einfach nur deren Überwachungsrichtung übernehmen. Das heißt, ein konkretes Beispiel, was wir ja auch im öffentlichen Diskurs heute ganz konkret haben, ist beispielsweise, dass ich Polizeibeamte zurückfilmen kann, wenn sie mich filmen, oder selbst dann, wenn sie nicht einfach nur mich filmen, sondern meinetwegen jemanden zu verhaften suchen. Wir hatten das, also beispielsweise, ganz bekanntes Beispiel in der Netzszene, ist natürlich so, dass Filmen, diese Polizeigewalt-Vorfälle auf der Freiheit statt Angst-Demo, da haben wir dann halt eine Situation, wo wir durchaus ein Interesse haben, dass so die Privatsphäre des Polizeibeamten weniger wert ist, als jetzt der Anspruch der Öffentlichkeit zu sehen, wie er mit anderen Leuten umspringt.
Man kann ja auch klar argumentieren, dass in dem Moment, wo man ein öffentliches Amt ausübt, dass das ja nicht unbedingt jetzt Teil der Privatsphäre ist.
Ja, aber genau diese Frage, dass ein öffentliches Amt plötzlich einen eigenen, dass man Anspruch hat gegenüber Öffentlich, gegenüber sagen wir mal Beamten, dass deren Handeln öffentlich ist, das ist ja durchaus von ein Ergebnis dieser Logik, dass Macht transparent sein muss. Das finden wir auch unterschiedlich stark verwirklicht. Also in Deutschland beispielsweise haben wir halt solche Sachen wie das Amtsgeheimnis oder dass sich durchaus Polizisten so etwas wie der Kennzeichnungspflicht entziehen, während wir in anderen Ländern halt sowas, also beispielsweise in Skandinavien haben wir das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip und in den USA beispielsweise ist es sehr üblich, dass Polizeigewalt sehr breit dokumentiert wird und Polizisten nicht einfach dann darauf pochen können, dass sie irgendwie ein Recht am eigenen Bild hätten, sondern stattdessen halt polizeiliche Handlungen massiv publiziert werden und das sogar gesetzlich geregelt ist in vielen Fällen. Das heißt, es ist durchaus eine Machtfrage, die immer noch ausgehandelt wird, ob jetzt staatliche Gewalt beispielsweise transparent zu sein hat. Und jetzt wäre quasi die Konsequenz aus, okay, wir werden immer mehr überwacht zu fordern, okay, korrelierend mit diesem Wir als Objekte des Staates oder müssen halt gleichzeitig immer größere Transparenz gegenüber denen einzufordern, die uns überwachen wollen, damit kein neues Machtungleichgewicht entsteht. Wo es halt irgendwie einen Big Brother gibt, der irgendwie alles weiß, was unter ihm geschieht und alle unter ihm halt diesen Blick ausgeliefert sind, ohne zurückblicken zu können und ohne beispielsweise zu schauen, inwieweit jetzt die Macht, die Big Brother verwendet, um dann aus seinem Wissen gegen uns zu handeln, gerechtfertigt ist. Also ob beispielsweise relativ korrupt ausgewählt wird, wer jetzt für ein adeptes Vergehen bestraft wird oder inwiefern das jetzt den demokratisch legitimierten Regeln folgt.
Das ist ja auch interessant, das ist ja auch eine sehr sehr tradierte netzpolitische Forderung eigentlich. Also ich meine, der CCC fordert auch schon seit Ewigkeiten den maschinenlesbaren Staat und mehr Transparenz auf staatlicher Seite. Insofern ist ja diese Post-Privacy-Utopie oder die Transparenz-Utopie durchaus auch in dieser netzpolitischen Szene durchaus sehr sehr vital und hat sich bisher noch nicht so deutlich mit dem Datenschutz gebissen.
Die Maschinenlesbare Regierung, die Forderung gibt es auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. In den 80er Jahren hat man sich wahrscheinlich schlapp gelacht über diese Forderungen, weil die klang irgendwie so mega absurd, wie das alle, was weiß ich, dass der Bundeskanzler im rosa Tütü öffentliche Auftritte durchführen sollte, weil man sich das überhaupt nicht vorstellen konnte. Und ich merke jedes Jahr, wie diese Forderungen in zunehmendem Maße immer realistischer, greifbarer und geradezu selbstverständlich wird. Also ich bin mir sicher, es wird stattfinden irgendwann.
Ich war sehr begeistert von dieser Seite, die ich neulich gefunden habe, wo der Bundeshaushalt sehr schön maschinenlesbar visualisiert aufgeschlüsselt war.
Es passiert im Prinzip nämlich schon in kleinen Schritten, nur dass es noch nicht unbedingt der Staat selber ist, der da jetzt die Schritte ergreift. Aber ich denke, es wird irgendwann eine Generation von Politikern einfach da sein, die so sehr von den 80er, 90er und wahrscheinlich jetzt hier auch diesen Nullerjahren oder wie man sie auch nennen soll, geprägt sind, sodass das auch überhaupt gar keine Diskussion mehr sein wird, dass das natürlich selbstverständlich so zu passieren hat. Wir haben jetzt eine ganze Menge Felder aufgemacht. Ich versuche gerade mal so ein bisschen, das so ein bisschen zu sortieren. Was mir jetzt noch so ein bisschen fehlt, ich meine, wir haben immer so dieses Ding, wie gehe ich jetzt sozusagen persönlich damit um? Also sehr häufig sind es eben auch sehr persönliche Entscheidungen. Und man merkt in allen Debatten, der eine ist da so gestrickt, der andere ist so gestrickt und das passt irgendwie nicht unbedingt immer zusammen. Wie haltet ihr es denn konkret selbst? Weil Duplom, weiß ich, bist tendenziell eher der Öffentlichkeit zugeneigter Mensch, aber wirst ja sicherlich auch noch so einen Privatspernausschnitt, die erhalten haben. Insbesondere eben jetzt auch als Netzbürger, was wir ja schon ganz am Anfang erwähnt haben, so Feindbild-Facebook-Nutzer. Vorher waren es Leute, die in Webforen alles reinschreiben oder die in Blogs alles über ihr Leben mitteilen. Das war ja schon immer so das Feindbild des Hackers. In den 80er-Jahren, 90er-Jahren, Anfang der 90er-Jahre, da waren wir ja noch irgendwie so im Internet noch so ein bisschen unter sich. Dann 1995 brachen langsam alle Dämme. Und jeden Tag hatte das Internet mehr neue Benutzer, die es einen Tag vorher noch nicht benutzt haben, als es vorher insgesamt Benutzer gab. Und so der gemeine Hacker lebte in fortwährender Angst. Oh Gott, jetzt kommen die hier alle in unsere Privatsphäre-Internet sozusagen. Die kommen ja irgendwie alle eingebrochen und die wissen ja überhaupt nicht, wie man sich zu benehmen hat. Und die posten alle, schreiben überall ihre Daten hin, die Sitten verrohen. Ich übertreibe jetzt mal so ein bisschen bewusst. So wir werden da alle drunter leiden. Niemand weiß mehr, was die Netikette ist etc. Ihr seid ja auch so ein bisschen Kinder dieser Zeit. Wie ist denn das bei euch? Also was für eine Bedeutung hat das Verhältnis Privatsphäre zur Öffentlichkeit für euch?
Also ich bin eigentlich ursprünglich rein sozialisiert, tatsächlich mehr so in die Netzparanoia. Im Sinne von ich habe immer all die Prämissen abgenickt. Ja, wir sollten alles verschlüsseln und der Staat wird uns überall überwachen. Und das ist nicht gut und deshalb versuchen wir da irgendwas gegenzusetzen und halt Informationen gefützt zu halten und privat zu halten. Gleichzeitig hat das dann aber immer weniger mit meiner eigentlich mit meiner tatsächlichen Praxis korreliert, weil ich dann doch immer mehr Spaß hatte, so an meiner digitalen Identität zu arbeiten und Sachen beispielsweise zu archivieren. Und in Zwiffen ist es so, dass ich es mir teilweise aus, teilweise weil ich es schon immer so mache, aber teilweise auch so ein bisschen als Experiment es halt tatsächlich erlaube, sehr viele Sachen, die viele Menschen verfeindlich für sich privat halten würden, durchaus in die Netzöffentlichkeit zu entlassen. Das heißt, was natürlich so ein Netzbürger oft tut, ist natürlich irgendwie sehr unkontrolliert, beispielsweise Sachen zu twittern. Aber bei mir ist das dann halt noch so ein paar Stufen größer, dass man halt eigentlich bei mir, wenn man beispielsweise auf meinen Wiki geht, durchaus meinen gesamten Tagesablauf nachvollziehen kann, zumindest in einer gewissen Auflösung. Das ist natürlich alles nicht total Post-Privacy. Das heißt, es gibt natürlich immer Bereiche, die dann nicht abgebildet sind oder die auch einfach von aus meiner Unfähigkeit tatsächlich jeden meiner Atemzüge zu protokollieren nicht abgebildet sind. Oder halt auch, weil ich tatsächlich entscheide, ok, beispielsweise das und das, was jetzt nur mich betrifft, das ist jetzt mein Problem, da brauche ich mich nicht sorgen, das kann ich auch der Öffentlichkeit geben, da habe ich jetzt nicht groß was zu befürchten, aber wenn ich beispielsweise Informationen habe, die eigentlich andere Leute betreffen und die mich aber auch gleichzeitig selbst betreffen, die ich also eigentlich aus, wenn ich tatsächlich alles komplett erfassen und protokollieren würde wollen, auch protokollieren müsste, dann gehe ich damit dann schon irgendwie vorsichtiger um, das heißt dann identifiziere ich halt nicht jede Person mit Namen, mit der ich jetzt beispielsweise Zeit verbringe, das heißt ich habe durchaus da auch noch so Sachen, wo ich sage, okay, da ziehe ich so Grenzen oder da habe ich auch einfach noch wieder die Zeit, noch die Lust irgendwie alles öffentlich breit zu treten, aber ich versuche das so experimentell zu gucken, was passiert, wenn ich in vielen Bereichen, die eigentlich traditionell privat sind, öffentlich zu werden und ich Und ich habe auch, ich gewöhne mir auch an für immer größere Teile meines Lebens, so aus so einem Stoizist dürfen, nimm immer das Schlimmstmögliche an, halt für mich so im Kopf immer schon so zu handeln. Okay, nehme jetzt einfach mal an, dass das durchaus öffentlich werden könnte, auch wenn ich es jetzt nicht absichtlich öffentlich stelle. Das heißt, verhalte dich nicht in einer Weise, die dir nachher peinlich sei. Oder gewöhne dir einfach an, dass dir Sachen nicht mehr peinlich sind. Ja, das ist ja ein subjektives Empfinden, ob einem eine Sache peinlich ist.
Also ich habe da jetzt gar nicht so ein großes Konzept, mit dem ich jetzt mein Leben gestalte, um jetzt eine Post-Privacy-Leben zu führen. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass man da so ein bisschen hineingesogen wird. Das ging los mit Blogs und mit Twitter und so weiter und so fort. Dann gab es zum Beispiel diesen Formspring-Geschichte, wo man dann irgendwie Fragen gestellt bekommt. Dann habe ich mich irgendwie plötzlich gesehen, wie ich da so total intime Details meines Lebens reingeschrieben habe. Ich habe mir gedacht, was mache ich hier eigentlich? Na egal, abdrücken. Einfach auch zum Beispiel um zu gucken. Es ist auch so eine ständige Grenzüberschreitung. Also ich weiß noch, wie ich damals gesehen habe, als es dieses Google-Lattitude gab. Das war so der erste so persönliche Social-Location-Service, wo man so seine Freunde in seinem Dings hat und immer sehen kann, wo seine Freunde sind. Und das wird auch noch automatisch im Hintergrund sozusagen immer, also jedenfalls, wenn man das richtige Handy dazu hat, wird das immer aktualisiert. Und dann habe ich erst mal gedacht, so wenn Hitler und Stalin sich zusammen einen Web 2.0-Tool ausgedacht hätten, dann wäre wahrscheinlich das... Also aber nein, ich habe mir... Es erschreckt einen, wenn man das zum ersten Mal hat. Und dann denkt man sich, boah ist das krass. Und dann denkt man sich, boah ist das geil. Und dann habe ich mich da angemeldet. Und es ist natürlich auch immer eine Erfahrung, dass hey, es tut tatsächlich gar nicht weh. Ja, so hey, das ist, auch wenn du jetzt... Ja, auch wenn es halt zum ersten Mal irgendwie so gegen einen... Wenn man da erst mal so eine Angst für spürt, sag ich mal, es tut nicht wirklich weh.
Also das Problem ist ja, die These der Information in der Selbststimmung ist ja, dass es wehtut oder dass es zumindest das eigene Verhalten halt durchaus einschränkt und es einem halt, weil man halt Angst hat davor, dass es einem peinlich sein könnte oder weil man dafür Konsequenzen befürchtet, Sachen halt nicht tut. Und ich glaube, wenn man so sehr frei, lernt sehr freigiebig mit Sachen umzugehen und sehr früh beginnt halt, sich diese Peinlichkeit oder diese Sorge abzugewöhnen, dass dann tatsächlich zumindest dieser Druck als psychologischer Druck halt abnehmen kann. Auch wenn natürlich durchaus mal die Gefahr immer noch da sein kann, dass einem beispielsweise dann Strafe folgt. Allerdings hat man dann weniger die Sorge vor irgendeinem metaphysischen Gefahr, die jetzt theoretisch möglich sein könnte, wenn der Staat mal strenger wird oder so. Sondern man hat dann mehr so ein, ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, das und das bereitet mir keinen Faden, also kann ich das auch ohne Sorge halt öffentlich tun.
Und was ich auch echt wirklich, also ich glaub, ich glaub, das Beste oder das Größte, was ich in dieser Hinsicht irgendwie erfahren habe, ist die Macht vom Kockettieren. Also wenn man tatsächlich Dinge hat, die einem peinlich sind, wenn man wirklich Dinge hat, die man bei sich irgendwie als Fehler kennt, dann ist das ein unglaublicher psychologischer Stress, die immer wieder zu verdecken und immer zu versuchen, dass diese Dinge nicht ans Tageslicht kommen. Aber man wird eine Erfahrung machen, wenn man diese Dinge öffentlich macht, wenn man damit offen umgeht. Dann macht man eigentlich regelmäßig die Erfahrung, dass man einerseits Verständnis von fast allen erntet und zweitens vor allem auch eine ganze Menge Leute plötzlich sich selber auch wiederum diese Dinge von sich aus aussprechen. Also meinen Aussprechen von irgendwelchen Dingen, die provozieren dann andere Leute wiederum, denen das ähnlich geht.
Also wenn man es sich leisten kann, dann baut es halt psychologischen Stress ab. Nicht nur in dem Sinne von, dass mir halt Sachen vielleicht tatsächlich weniger peinlich sind, sondern auch, dass ich nicht mehr genötigt bin, ständig zu überlegen, kann ich das jetzt in dieser Situation öffentlich machen oder nicht. Oder ist das eine Information, die ich in dem Bereich privat halten muss, auch wenn ich in dem anderen Bereich davon reden kann und deshalb ständig also im Grunde genommen Rollenspiele spielen muss, wo ich mir sage, ich bin jetzt in dem Kontext jemand, der würde das nie tun und der würde auch nie eingestehen, dass er das tut, während ich in einem anderen Text natürlich jemand bin, der eingestehen kann, dass er das tut, weil das vielleicht sogar dazugehört. Dieses ständige sichbewusstsein, in welchem Regelwerk befinde ich mich gerade, wo ich etwas sein darf oder nicht, das wird halt auch dadurch abgebaut, wenn man eine Information pauschal, total öffentlich macht. Das heißt, ich muss dann halt, okay, ich werde sie vielleicht nicht jedem Menschen, jedem Bereich aufdrängen müssen, aber ich muss dann nicht mehr im Hinterkopf behalten, ich würde jetzt einen großen Schaden anrichten, wenn es in diesem Bereich bekannt würde, denn eigentlich, wenn es irgendjemanden davon ernsthaft interessiert, dann wäre es ihm eh schon bekannt.
Ich meine, dieses Kockettieren ist ein bisschen idealistisch. Man könnte ja auch genauso gut argumentieren, in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt mit meinen Schwächen zu sehr rumkockettiere, öffne ich sozusagen auch das freie Feuer auf mich des Mobbings, je nachdem, wie so mein soziales Umfeld gestaltet ist. Diese Angst dürfte auf jeden Fall existieren.
Ja, es ist natürlich so, man muss da schon ein gewisses Grundsichtsvertrauen haben, damit man so etwas macht. Aber also wirklich, ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, für etwas, was man für einen Fehler, den man öffentlich einsteht, den man öffentlich macht, wird man nicht angegriffen. Also es gibt keine bessere Form, der nicht angreifbar sein, wenn man von vornherein Dinge zugibt. Dann können die immer noch, dann können die zwar sagen, ja das ist ja total scheiße, dass das so ist, ja, aber dann können die dir nicht mehr...
So die Zafar-Lobo-Strategie.
Ja, ohne Scheiß. Das kann man von ihm durchaus lernen, wobei er ja nicht wirklich von Shitstorms verschont bleibt. Aber ja, ich glaube schon, dass das eine ziemlich entwaffnende Sache ist. Also ich glaube tatsächlich Mobbing, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man da...
Ja, ich meine, bleiben wir dabei. Shitstorm, das ist definitiv ein Phänomen des Netzes. Und man kann sich eben schnell auch durch das, soll ich sagen, das Beziehen von einer Meinung schnell ins Feuer bringen. Das ist eine schwierige, was weiß ich hier, diese Sarrazin-Debatte. Ich meine, jetzt, nachdem sich so ein bisschen der Rauch gelegt hat, da kann man dann vielleicht auch mal mit diversifizierten Meinungen in die Debatte einsteigen, aber macht das mal zum Höhepunkt einer Empörungskurve, die durch die gesamte mediale Landschaft zieht. Da bist du schnell auch genauso mit im Shitstorm und gehst darin unter, auch wenn du eigentlich nur mal kurz den Finger heben wolltest, sagen wolltest, ob es denn vielleicht mal ganz angemessen wäre, vielleicht wenn man mal kurz ein bisschen...
Na gut, aber ich glaube, das ist gerade ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass ja so ein Shitstorm durchaus gewollt sein kann im Sinne von, plötzlich wird über dieses Thema öffentlich geredet und gestritten. Und man kann durchaus die Strategie vertreten, ich pack das jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit im vollen Bewusstsein, dass es kontrovers sein wird und dass es nicht mit den Normen vieler Leute in ihren Normen nicht damit klarkommen werden, eben weil man halt eine öffentliche Debatte darüber möchte. Das ist im Grunde genommen, man trollt so ein bisschen die Öffentlichkeit, um zu sehen, ob man nicht die Normen dadurch auch so ein bisschen in Frage stellen kann. Das ist ja eine alte Strategie des Fritz aus der Privatsphäre in die Öffentlichkeit zu emanzipativen Zwecken, dass man beispielsweise in der sexuellen Revolution plötzlich Sachen als öffentlichen Diskurs auftritt, vor denen man vorher gesagt hat, dass selbst wenn man das vielleicht duldet, dann aber nur bitte farmvoll und im privaten Raum. Aber es sollte nicht irgendwie öffentliche Debatte sein, denn eigentlich ist es trotzdem irgendwie schmutzig oder falsch, dass man dann halt tatsächlich sagt, genau diese Sache, die irgendwie peinlich sein soll und die als schmutzig oder falsch gilt, auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht ganz so illegal ist, von der bin ich da mein, die sollte eben nicht schmutzig und peinlich sein, sondern zu der sollte man öffentlich stehen können. Und dann provoziert man halt einen Sturm der Entrüstung, wenn man diese öffentlich macht, mit dem Ziel, dass das Durcheinander was das zur Folge hat zu einer Änderung der Toleranznormen, dass er beispielsweise die Schulenbewegung macht, als wenn sie Coming-outs provoziert und nicht nur Freiwillige, sondern auch Unfreiwillige, also Leute geoutet werden, vielleicht sogar zu ihrem eigenen privaten Nachteil, aber mit dem Ziel, dass die Gesellschaft ihre Einstellung zur Homosexualität beispielsweise überdenkt.
Ja und der Thilo Sarrazin, der wusste ja auch relativ genau, worauf er sich einlässt, glaube ich. Er hatte ja schon diverse Shitstorms provoziert mit Interviews und Artikeln und da wusste schon ziemlich genau, was er mit diesem Buch auslösen wollte. Also ich glaube, das hat ihn nicht überrascht.
Bleiben wir mal kurz auch in diesem Bereich. Also wir hatten ja schon einiges über Privatsphäre geredet vorhin. Michael, das war auch schon angedeutet, du forderst sozusagen auch eine Öffentlichkeit, wie ich das dann formuliert habe, als Schutz vor gesellschaftlichem Untergang. Also es bedarf sozusagen einer Öffentlichwerdung. Es gab dann einen schönen Diskurs. Das war auch so ein Moment, wo ich so ein bisschen die Idee für das Gespräch heute so in der Konstellation auch gefunden habe, diese Sache mit der Einführung von LiquidFeedback in der Piratenpartei, wo es ja dann auch eine Debatte gab, die mit Datenschutz argumentierte. Also soll das sozusagen jetzt als Werkzeug für unsere Meinungsbildung innerhalb der Partei eingeführt werden und inwieweit kann jetzt von mir als Parteimitglied erwartet werden, dass ich innerhalb dieses Systems nachvollziehbar, also öffentlich, Position beziehe? Da gab es dann Pro und Contra. Das hat man ja dann so ein bisschen auch in der Twitter-Öffentlichkeit und an anderen Stellen wurde das ja dann auch heiß debattiert über ein paar Tage. Du hast dann einen Blog-Eintrag dazu geschrieben, der ganz interessante Parallelen zog, wie ich fand, unter anderem mit Rückgriff auf die 68er und so ähnliche, ich glaube, es kam aus dieser Feminismus-Debatte, so das Private darf sozusagen die Politik nicht einnehmen. Ich das jetzt richtig interpretiere. Man braucht sozusagen die Öffentlichkeit an der Stelle, damit sich das eben dieser Öffentlichkeit nicht entzieht.
Ja, also es ist natürlich ein politischer Blick auf, was ist privat und was öffentlich. Und wenn man etwas als privat deklariert, dann entzieht man es dem Öffentlichen und damit auch dem politischen Diskurs. Und das ist das, was die Frauenbewegung ja gesagt hat, wie Plomm auch schon vorhin angemerkt hat, indem es halt sozusagen diese private Sphäre gibt, in der der Mann dann eben die Frau vergewaltigen kann. Und das ist total okay, weil es spielt sich ja nicht in der Öffentlichkeit ab, sondern es ist im Privaten und so weiter. Dann entzieht man sozusagen die Beziehung zwischen Mann und Frau und die Beziehung in der Familie entzieht man dem politischen Diskurs. Und das konnte die Frauenbewegung natürlich nicht zulassen, weil die Frauenbewegung ist eine politische Bewegung, die genau diese Dinge neu regeln will. Und das heißt mit anderen Worten, sie will dort ja auch tatsächlich in den privaten Bereich eindringen. Also sie will da sozusagen in privaten Änderungen haben.
Sehr gut, aber häusliche Gewalt jetzt sozusagen als Prügelargum hinten warst du das Wort, das heranzuziehen für eine Debatte mit wie soll unsere politische Diskussion gehen?
Meinst du, das passt zusammen? Also bei LiquidFeedback finde ich vor allem interessant. LiquidFeedback ist ja von vielen bejubelt, unter anderem auch von mir. Das ist gleich auch eine Sendung schon mal drüber gemacht, ist ein Tool, mit dem man tatsächlich eine völlig neue Form von Demokratie einführt, die es vorher so nicht gab und die es auch noch nicht geben konnte.
Ich würde mal sagen, man probiert sie aus.
Ja, man probiert sie aus, genau. Und wir haben eben bei LiquidFeedback das entsprechende Problem, was wir aus den Wahlcomputern ja kennen, was der CCC ja zu genüge gezeigt hat, dass man eben nicht gleichzeitig eine Wahl nachvollziehbar und geheim machen kann mit dem Computer und deswegen sind natürlich alle Abstimmungsergebnisse und alle Delegationen bei LiquidFeedback öffentlich. Was durchaus auch eine der Hauptforderungen von der Piratenpartei ist, eben nach der transparenten Politik und sie hat ja auch einen eigenen Anspruch an transparente Politik und das beißt sich dann eben auch mit dem Datenschutz beziehungsweise einzelne Piratenmitglieder haben dann eben die geheime Abstimmung gefordert, weil sie eben nicht sich eingucken lassen wollten in die Karten, wie sie jetzt für entsprechende Themen votieren und so weiter. Und ja, und da hatten wir dann eben diesen Konflikt und ich glaube, das Interessante ist halt, dass halt so drei Ansprüche miteinander kollidieren. Also einerseits, dass wir, genau, es gab dann tatsächlich auch diese Diskussion, unter anderem wurde dann immer wieder betont, ja, man könnte doch jetzt aber eine Grenze einziehen, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, Leute, die ein Mandat haben in der Partei, die sind dann öffentlich und alle anderen sind nicht öffentlich, was das Problem natürlich nicht löst, aber das war so, ich fand das ganz interessant, weil es dann wieder so eine Wir-und-die-Grenze gibt, ja, also die sollen bitte privat bleiben und wir, die sollen bitte öffentlich sein, aber wir wollen privat bleiben.
Selber fullt, wenn du in die Öffentlichkeit trittst.
Ja, genau, und also was wir ja auch durchaus kennen, Datenschutz für die Bürger und einen transparenten Staat halt diese beiden Forderungen, die sich in LiquidFeedback dann sozusagen auf dieser politischen Parteibase es nochmal wiederholt haben. Und der Witz ist ja aber, dass genau LiquidFeedback eigentlich angetreten ist, genau diese Grenze aufzulösen zwischen Politiker und einfachem Wahlvolk. Also das ist ja genau der Punkt, dass eben durch das Delegationsprinzip jeder irgendwie ein bisschen Politiker sein kann und jeder irgendwie ein bisschen trotzdem Bürger ist und dass das sich eben nicht mehr mit klaren kategorialen Grenzen eben abspielt. Da ist der Politiker und da ist der Bürger.
Wobei, ich würde jetzt den Vergleich mit Wahlvolk jetzt so erstmal nicht ziehen wollen, weil wir reden ja hier um die Partei sozusagen, wobei, da beginnt dann glaube ich auch eben die Diskussion, was ist denn sozusagen eine Partei in der Gesellschaft? Warum geht man denn in die Partei? Man geht in die Partei, um die Politik zu beeinflussen und man tut es dort in einer Organisation, die eben nur dafür gemacht ist, das zu tun, verlässt man sozusagen in dem Moment, wo man so eine Partei betritt per Default die Privatsphäre des Politischen sozusagen?
Ja, und da ist ja tatsächlich genau der Punkt, dass den Hannah Arendt ja anspricht, also sie definiert ja das Öffentliche vom Politischen her. Also die politische Handlung an sich ist und das politische Sein und das politisch Agieren. Das ist für sie eigentlich der Inbegriff von Öffentlichkeit. Und wenn wir dann eben in einer Partei sind, dann haben wir schon den Schritt sozusagen in die Öffentlichkeit getan. Und wenn wir auf eine Demo sind, und das fand ich auch interessant, jetzt wieder auf dieser Freiheit statt Angst, da gibt es dann eben so T-Shirt-Verkäufer, die verkaufen T-Shirts mit, bitte fotografiert mich nicht oder sowas. Ja, und also die Leute, die Angst haben, die, ich meine, die Demonstration hat nichts anderes, keinen anderen Zweck als in die Öffentlichkeit zu treten, mit mir als Person, als öffentliche Person und für eine bestimmte Meinung öffentlich einzustehen, ja. Und wenn man da ein Problem hat, fotografiert zu werden, dann ist das irgendwie ein bisschen schizophren.
An der Stelle möchte ich aber auch einen Gegenthese anbringen, die auch durchaus existiert, dass nämlich das Private durchaus politisch notwendig sei, weil das Private ist ja ein Raum, der gewissermaßen der öffentlichen Kontrolle entzogen ist. Die Öffentlichkeit hat zu ihre Normen, was sie duldet und was nicht und natürlich auch welche politischen Positionen sie duldet und welche nicht und welche politischen Gedanken sie duldet und welche nicht. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass bestimmte politische Entwicklungen, Gedankenbildungen, Vorgehensweisen überhaupt nur entstehen können außerhalb der Überwachung durch die Öffentlichkeit in einem privaten Rückzugsraum, in einem Hinterzimmer, wo Leute jetzt verbotene Lektüren durchführen, sich über verbotene Dinge austauschen und dann daraus sich so langsam ein politischer Stachel entwickeln kann, der vielleicht irgendwann fertig entwickelt, als in die Öffentlichkeit tritt, der aber vorher zu seiner Genese tatsächlich das Private braucht, weil nur dort er hinreichend unabhängig ist von der Repression, die die Öffentlichkeit hat, um ihre politischen Normen durchzusetzen.
Ja, das ist durchaus der Fall. Aber wir hatten vorhin das kurz angerissen, aber nicht zu Ende gebracht. Und zwar, wo wir an dem Punkt waren, zu sagen, okay, das, was wir Öffentlichkeit nennen, das gibt es eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr so, beziehungsweise es zerfällt gerade. Und also bei Hanna Arendt kann man jetzt nicht stehen bleiben. Also Hanna Arendt ist ja die, die definiert das auch genauso. Sie sagt auch tatsächlich, es braucht diesen Bereich des politischen, des privaten und diese Grenze, die man überschreitet, hin in die Öffentlichkeit. Aber ich würde das ganz gerne, diesen Begriff, nachdem wir ihn groß stark gemacht haben, jetzt noch mal ein bisschen hinterfragen, diesen Begriff der Öffentlichkeit. Weil da schwingt dann immer mit, dass es so ein homogenes, monolithisches Ganzes gäbe. Also ein Gesellschafts-Korpus mit einer sogenannten öffentlichen Meinung und einem allgemeinen Diskurs und so etwas. Es wird halt mal als etwas durchaus sehr homogenes dargestellt, was es ja in Wirklichkeit gar nicht ist. Und das ist jetzt, würde ich sagen, da kommt jetzt dieser Kontrollverlust auch mit rein, der ja eben nicht nur der Kontrollverlust der Privatsphäre ist, sondern auch der Kontrollverlust zum Beispiel der klassischen Medien, die durchaus, dadurch, dass sie die gesellschaftlichen Diskurse durch dieses Nadelöhr ihrer zentralistischen Verteilungsorgane gepresst haben, tatsächlich so etwas wie eine Illusion einer öffentlichen Meinung und eines allgemeinen Diskurses haben durchsetzen können, dass die ja ihre Macht verlieren und dass diese Diskurse tatsächlich in solchen partiellen Teilöffentlichkeiten stattfinden. Ja, ich meine, wir sehen das ja alle über Blogs und Twitter und etc., das halt und auch über Facebook, dass die Leute sich in einer mehr oder weniger Halböffentlichkeit oder Partialöffentlichkeit unterhalten, die abgekoppelt sind von, also nicht völlig abgekoppelt, aber durchaus eigenständig sind gegenüber den Massenmedien. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, ich kann halt zum Beispiel mittlerweile durch meinen Twitter-Account eben einen Diskurs führen, der so und so viele tausend Leute erreicht, der dann eben nicht mehr etwas gemein haben muss mit dem allgemeinen Diskurs, der über die Tagesschau und so weiter und so fort transportiert wird, der aber eben eine Partialöffentlichkeit darstellt und einen Subdiskurs eröffnen kann.
Die Blase der Netzgemeinde.
Genau. Und das ist ja auch das, was viele Leute momentan auch ängstigt. Ja, also diese demokratische Öffentlichkeit, die zersplittert in diese ganzen Partialöffentlichkeiten durch das Internet, wird es plötzlich jedem möglich sozusagen nur noch mit seiner Subkultur zu kommunizieren und sich über seine Subkultur auszutauschen und sich gar nicht mehr an dem allgemeinen Diskurs, gesellschaftlichen Diskurs.
Die digitale Parallelgesellschaft?
Genau, also die vielen kleinen digitalen Parallelgesellschaften. Das wurde auch letztens wieder formuliert. Und der David Precht hat das auch mal formuliert, glaube ich, auf einer Konferenz. Und es gab jetzt wieder einen neuen Artikel, habe ich jetzt gesehen, ich weiß nicht mehr, wo er entschieden ist. Gerade gestern kam mir das wieder unter. Das kommt immer wieder unter so. Und das ist auch gar nicht so falsch. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das, was wir sozusagen, diesen öffentlichen Diskurs und was wir als diese monolithische Öffentlichkeit kennen, dass das durchaus zersplittert wird. Und dort kommt dann auch wiederum sozusagen dieser Schutzraum, oder dieser abgesteckte private Raum, in den sich parallel zu dem gesellschaftlichen Diskurs, den es hoffentlich bald nicht mehr gibt, halt solche...
Fassen wir endlich die Gesellschaft ab.
Ja, beziehungsweise, dass sich da dann eben solche Diskurse durchaus bilden können, weil es eben solche Partialöffentlichkeiten gibt, die nicht abgeschottet sind, auf keinen Fall abgeschottet sind. Das ist ja auch immer diese Angst von diesen Leuten, dass die dann sich total abschotten, das stimmt ja gar nicht. Dass es ja eben keine zentralistische, sondern eine Netzwerkstruktur ist, kann sie sich ja gar nicht abschotten.
Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, bewertest du das jetzt eigentlich irgendwie, wenn ja wie, oder nimmst du das jetzt einfach nur zur Kenntnis, dass solche Parallelstrukturen durch das Internet ermöglicht werden und existieren? Ich finde das jetzt nicht so besonders, weil diese Parallelgesellschaften, in dem Sinne gab es ja, ich meine, gab es schon immer. Ich meine, jeder hat so in seiner Peer-Group sozusagen seinen politischen Diskurs geführt oder eben auch nicht. Und erst sehr spät kommt das zusammen. Dann könnte man jetzt genauso argumentieren im Internet, naja, kann das einerseits sehr viel breiter, also sehr viel mehr Leute umfassen, schneller laufen und lässt sich ja dann auch noch sehr viel einfacher, theoretisch zumindest, wieder zusammenführen. Und man hat eben eine sehr viel breite, also in der politischen Diskussion sehr viel breiter aufgestellte Gesellschaft durch die Nutzung von Kommunikationsmittel.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, es ist schon doch ein qualitativer Unterschied. Natürlich hattest du immer deinen Stammtisch, natürlich hattest du auch immer deine Freunde und deine Familie, mit denen du über diese Dinge geredet hast. Aber das war erstens eine sehr, sehr kleine Öffentlichkeit und du warst natürlich für die Informationsvermittlung immer noch von den klassischen Medien total abhängig. Das ist zum Teil heute auch noch so, aber es nimmt ab. Das kann man auch durchaus so sagen. Also die Informationsfluss selbst der jetzt nicht Twitterer und Hardcore-Blogger wird zunehmend dadurch bestimmt, dass sie zum Beispiel durch ihren Facebook-Feed informiert werden und solche Sachen. Also das ist schon so etwas, das durchaus mittlerweile in den Mainstream ankommt, wo die Massenmedien halt dann plötzlich nur noch ein oder sind auch nur noch Player in diesem riesigen großen Netzwerk wußt. Und nicht eben dieser krasse Backbone, der es vorher halt war.
Also früher mussten alle die Tagefrau gucken, wenn sie informiert sein wollten. Und heute habe ich die Wahl zwischen 1000 anderen Formaten und habe nicht mehr diesen einen gemeinsamen Informationshintergrund mit allen Leuten.
Und nicht mehr den gleichen Blick unbedingt auf die Geschehnisse wie zum Beispiel der Mainstream. Ich kann halt zum Beispiel, wenn ich eben Cilusarrazin toll finde, kann ich halt auch meinen gesamten Blick auf die Medienlandschaft kann ich halt über PI filtern lassen und dann habe ich zum Beispiel ein ganz anderes Weltbild. Das ist ja der Fall und das passiert ja auch. Und da gibt es ja auch ganz krude Verschwörungsseiten und so weiter und so fort und das sind auch teilweise Leute, die sich dann durchaus in gewissem Maße sozusagen vom allgemeinen Mainstream-Diskurs auch sehr, sehr dezidiert abkoppeln und die mittlerweile auch durchaus ihre eigenen Medien haben, die sie eben so bespielen, wie sie es ganz gerne hätten. Und ja, das passiert und das passiert auch immer weiter und das ist erstmal etwas, das ich durchaus erstmal feststelle. Aber ich wollte dadurch hin zu sagen, es wird durchaus diesen Öffentlichkeitsdiskurs nochmal aufnehmen, weil wir hatten jetzt gerade die Öffentlichkeit so stark gemacht und jetzt sagen wir, okay, diese eine Öffentlichkeit, die gibt es aber gar nicht mehr, diese eine demokratische Diskursöffentlichkeit. Ja, das ist eben jetzt das Interessante, dass man dann irgendwie jetzt gucken muss. Wenn wir jetzt mal wieder zurück auf den Datenschutz bezogen, wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr kontrollieren kann, welche Daten jetzt von mir an welche Person durch sie kann oder von mir öffentlich gemacht werden oder mit welchen Daten verknüpft werden und welches Bild von mir generiert wird, dann muss diese Macht ja irgendwo anders hingehen und das geht halt eben tatsächlich immer zu demjenigen, der eben eine Abfrage an die Daten macht. Also wenn wir uns die Datenbank-Technologie anschauen, dann ist es ja genauso, dass sie die Macht genommen hat von demjenigen, der speichert, hin zu demjenigen, der die Datenbank abfragt. Beispiel SQL. Also die Erfindung von SQL halte ich dafür für einen sehr, sehr paradigmatischen Schritt. Also zu sagen, derjenige, der abfragt, der bestimmt die Ordnung der Daten und die Verknüpfung der Daten und was dann tatsächlich die Aussage sein soll, während derjenige, der die Tabellen anlegt, eigentlich nicht wirklich vorher determinieren kann und sich überlegen muss, wie jetzt diese Daten abgefragt wird, sondern dass diese Kontrollmacht über, welche Informationen jetzt wirklich generiert werden, eben eins vor allem bei demjenigen liegt, der sie abfragt.
Also du meinst jetzt vor allem solche Eigenschaften wie Views, dass ich sozusagen sagen kann, verknüpfe dieses mit diesem, diese, diese, die und da und so weiter.
Und das ist eben das Interessante, finde ich. Und ich finde dafür, die Datenbank ist für mich immer das paradigmatische Beispiel für diesen Kontrollverlust. Und das macht es ja überhaupt erst aus, dass ich zum Beispiel nicht sagen kann, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Bild von mir bei Flickr hochposte, dann kann ich nicht sagen, was übermorgen aus diesem Bild alles noch für Daten herausgezogen werden können. Also ich kann zwar jetzt sagen, ich packe die Geolocation rein, aber welche Gesichter jetzt darauf irgendwann mit welcher Software irgendwie identifiziert werden können und wiederum verknüpft werden mit Profildaten aus anderen Social Networks, die dann wiederum verknüpft werden mit Twitterern oder wie auch immer.
Ja und das Rauschmuster deiner Kamera, mit der ID der Kamera, deren Kaufdatum.
Was weiß ich, alles so. Das sind alles solche Dinge, die dann eben nicht mehr in meiner Hand liegen, sondern eben in demjenigen des Abfragers.
Und diese Abfrager, um das mal zu konkretisieren, das können halt Neonazis sein, die jetzt irgendwie sammeln, wo jetzt irgendwelche linkslastigen Menschen halt meinetwegen ihre Familie unterbringen, damit sie dann irgendwie dort böse Sachen damit machen. Oder das können beispielsweise Perverse sein, die irgendwie meine Flickerbilder, das ist irgendwie ein vollverliebtes Problem, die irgendwie meine harmlosen Flickerbilder von was weiß ich, meinen Socken, die meine Füße umfassen, benutzen, um halt dort ihre Wichsvorlagen zusammenzustellen. Das sind beides halt Fälle, die auftreten. Das heißt, das Problem, was ich dann halt habe, ist, dass ich eben nicht mehr nur weiß, dass irgendwie nur diese eigentlich mir wohlmeinende Öffentlichkeit, an der ich teilhabe, darauf zugreift, sondern irgendwelche Terroristen oder sonst welche bösen Menschen. Und wie gehe ich dann damit um, dass ich plötzlich weiß, diese Information interessiert vielleicht niemanden, der jetzt irgendwie sie benutzen könnte, um jetzt beispielsweise Futs mir gegenüber aufzubauen, sondern halt Leute, die halt die Information nur für die böses denkbaren Zwecke vielleicht benutzen.
Ja, um das noch mal ein bisschen zu Ende zu führen. Also ich glaube, man kann das natürlich konkretisieren und man kann dort auch Bedrohungssanarien aufbauen. Man kann aber auch sagen, das wird vielleicht der Historiker sein, der später halt mit Datenanalyse-Modellen, also ich denke auch mal, die Historiker in naher Zukunft werden mit durchaus Datenanalyse-Techniken an die vergangene Gegenwart herangehen. Das können durchaus, es kann vielleicht mein späterer Biograph sein. Das kann halt jemand in der Zukunft sein mit einer völlig anderen Technologie, von der ich heute noch gar keine Vorstellungen besitze. Das ist genauso, wie Tutankhamun sich nicht vorstellen konnte, dass er mal eine vollständige Krankenakte bekommen würde, nachdem wir bestimmte Cesium-Verfallsdatums-Technologien und Röntgen-Geschichten erfunden haben, von denen er sicherlich nicht mal in seinen Künstenträumen geträumt hat. Das ist eben dieser Fall, den wir in dieser Zeit, in der sich ja durchaus in dieser Hinsicht auch sehr beschleunigt hat, dass wir das selbst für die nächsten zwei Jahre eigentlich sehr, sehr unsicher bestimmen können. Und damit kommt dann jetzt eben ein Konzept von Öffentlichkeit zu Schrande, in der ich gerade sitze und demnächst auch mal einen Vortrag dazuhalten will. Und zwar eben eine Öffentlichkeit, die eben vom anderen her denkt. Also das heißt, diese Abfrage, auch vor allem diese zukünftige Abfrage von Daten und dieser zukünftiger Zugriff von Informationen über mich und über mein Schaffen oder über Daten, die ich irgendwo liegen hab lassen, die sind halt undefinierbar, die sind nicht vorstellbar und die sind nicht konkretisierbar. Man kann sich natürlich alles möglich ausmalen, wie der Nazi und den Fetischisten, aber man kann es eigentlich nicht wirklich. Und insofern muss man tatsächlich diese Öffentlichkeit halt eben von diesem Unbekannten her denken. Also dieser Unbekannte, der irgendwann mal meine Daten aus welchem Intention und mit welcher Technologie auch immer betrachten wird.
Nehmt mir das nicht jede Sicherheit? Also bin ich da nicht allem nur denkbaren Schlimmen ausgeliefert und kann überhaupt nicht mehr mir irgendeine Hoffnung machen, übermorgen noch heil weiterleben zu können?
Ja, beziehungsweise, also ich glaube, das ist ja eben der Witz. Also du kannst auf jeden Fall nicht kontrollieren, wer auf deine Daten wie zugreift. Das auf jeden Fall nicht. Das ist die Idee. Die Sache ist die, was tust du jetzt? Und ich glaube, das Beste ist tatsächlich, dass die Gesellschaft entsprechend auszupolstern, dass dieser Neonazi eben nicht dich morgen irgendwie mit der Keule erschlagen kann und du vielleicht aber trotzdem damit rechnen und damit erleben musst, dass sich der Fetischist auf deine Socken ein runterholt.
Ja, und ich glaube, dieses Gesellschaft auspolstern, das ist beispielsweise die Gesellschaft tatsächlich menschenfreundlicher oder toleranter und dergleichen zu machen. Das ist denke ich, das ist quasi das, worum es eigentlich in den politischen Kampf gehen sollte, der sich jetzt derzeit sehr darauf konzentriert, Leute davor zu schützen, indem man das Wissen über die Leute halt klein hält. Also beispielsweise zu sagen, wenn ihr weiter künftig einen Job bekommen wollt, dann solltet ihr geheim halten, dass ihr auf irgendwelche Partys geht und euch dort ungebührlich verhaltet, anstatt zu hinterfragen, warum ist denn das überhaupt relevant für den Arbeitgeber, dass man sich ungebührlich auf einer Party verhält.
Ja, und das ist auch eine Frage der Solidarität. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel mitkriegst, dass einer irgendwie einen Job nicht bekommen hat, weil er ein besoffenes Partyfoto hat, dann sollten vielleicht sogar die anderen ganz im Gegenteil halt erstmal alle ihre Fotos auf den Tisch legen und sagen, hier, bam, das ist doch ganz normal, da war ich auch auf der Party, guck mal, da lieg ich.
Das wirft allerdings, finde ich, das grundlegende politische Problem auf, inwiefern man denn überhaupt eine Verantwortung vielleicht sogar hat, die Privatsphäre auch abzustreifen und in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. Denn also wir sind jetzt alle hier sehr privilegiert und leben in einer sehr, an sich von sehr liberalen Gesellschaft, wo wir relativ wenig befürchten müssen, wenn so Harmlosigkeiten wie unser Sexualleben an die Öffentlichkeit treten. Allerdings ist das ja erstens nicht für alle Menschen so und zweitens selbst wir haben vielleicht irgendwelche Sachen, wo wir befürchten müssen, dass die Gesellschaft sich vielleicht nicht dulden würde, wenn wir sich in die Öffentlichkeit treten. Das heißt, es stellt sich eigentlich trotzdem immer wieder so eine Grenzziehungsfrage. Wo kann ich jetzt durchaus guten Gewissens sagen, okay, das wird mir keinen Faden bereiten, auch und vor allem natürlich im Hintergrund Gedanken, dass ich nicht mal abwägen kann, was vielleicht künftig mir Faden bereiten kann, weil die Daten da bleiben und vielleicht irgendwann ein künftiger anderer Machthaber oder irgendein ein anderer, wie du es halt so schon gesagt hast, mit den Daten irgendwas machen kann, was ich nicht vorausplanen kann. Wo muss ich halt das befürchten und wo nicht? Und ich glaube, es gibt halt tatsächlich so etwas wie eine Verantwortung zum Outing, die halt aber eben immer rückkoppelt ist mit dem, was man tatsächlich verkraften kann, was man sich halt leisten kann. Also ich glaube beispielsweise, dass man vielleicht von jemandem, der in einer extrem konservativen und repressiven und gewalttätigen Gesellschaft lebt, verlangen kann, dass er mit Sachen an die Öffentlichkeit geht, die von dieser Gesellschaft nicht geduldet werden. Das heißt, man kann eben nicht jetzt von irgendeinem Menschen im Iran verlangen, dass er jetzt plötzlich öffentlich dafür einsteht, ach ich bin übrigens ful und ihr solltet mal alle gefälligst eure Toleranznormen ändern, weil das würde wahrscheinlich ihn einfach nur zu Märtyrer machen. Dann können wir vielleicht hier sagen, ach das ist ja ehrenwert, dass er das gemacht hat und das finden wir in gewisser Weise sogar gut, aber man kann das nicht von Leuten verlangen, weil sie dann nämlich verfeindlich umgebracht werden dafür. Während wir jetzt hier in einem Umfeld leben, was tatsächlich relativ liberal ist, aufgrund politischer Kämpfe, die vielleicht sogar daran liegen, dass irgendwann mal Leute diese Märtyrer-Stellung eingenommen haben. Und ich glaube, man muss dann tatsächlich reflektieren, für Sachen, von denen ich möchte, dass die Gesellschaft demgegenüber tolerant bleibt oder tolerant wird, kann ich es mir da nicht tatsächlich vielleicht leisten, mit diesen Sachen einigermaßen öffentlich zu sein und halt auf diese Weise die Toleranznormen zugunsten meiner Lebensform zu beeinflussen. Also, dass das eine Abwägungssache ist, sich zu ins Feiden zu züffen, das würde mich jetzt zum Märtyrer machen und das ist einfach Solidarität gegenüber anderen Leuten, die das vielleicht doch nicht öffentlich machen können, weil sie beispielsweise vielleicht im Iran leben und ich auf diese Weise allerdings den Welttoleranznormen einer Weise anpassen kann, die irgendwann den Iran unter Druck setzt.
Du meinst also, man hat die Verpflichtung, die Toleranzgrenzen seiner Gesellschaft voll auszukosten, sozusagen.
Also sie zu sehen, wo sie liegen und zu gucken, dass man sie weiter in die erwünschte Richtung halt drückt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das normale gesellschaftliche Spiel und insofern auch eigentlich gar nichts Neues.
Ja, aber das ist ja durchaus dann auch eine Selbstverpflichtung für Liberale, für Leute in liberalen Gesellschaften, dass sie eben ihre sexuellen Neigungen oder ihre, oder sagen wir mal so, wo es strittige Punkte gibt in Sachen Toleranz, dass sie halt durchaus so eine gewisse Verpflichtung haben, diese Dinge durchaus an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, auch wenn sie Nachteile dadurch haben, weil sie dadurch den einzelnen Leuten, die vielleicht nicht ganz so in solchen Strukturen leben, die so liberal sind, dadurch helfen auch.
Wir haben ja auch die Anerkennung von Konzepten wie beispielsweise Farm, dass es durchaus gut ist, nicht alles an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, selbst wenn es vielleicht nicht illegal ist. Und wir haben, denke ich, durchaus auch in sowas wie dem Datenschutz oft eine Logik, die sagt, wir müssen diese Farm bewahren, wir müssen diese Farm-Grenzen auch aufrechterhalten, wir müssen zumindest die Instrumente dafür stärken, um diese Farm-Grenzen aufrechtzuerhalten. Und ich glaube, das ist einer der Punkte, wo sich Datenschutz politisch angreifbar macht, wenn er tatsächlich zu so etwas steht, wie wir müssen die Freiheit des Einzelnen schützen, weil er beispielsweise in erster Linie die Möglichkeiten stärkt, vor dem Arbeitgeber etwas geheim zu halten und nicht so sehr den Arbeitgeber unter Druck setzt, seine eigene Toleranz anzupassen.
Du hast ja in deinem Vortrag, ich glaube, es ist ja auch schon kurz angeklungen, hast du sozusagen von der Ideologie Datenschutz gesprochen?
Ja, das hat sich dann zwar eher ein bisschen später bei einem anderen Vortrag und bei einem anderen Text, aber ja, genau, sowas in die Richtung, dass halt Datenschutz so einige Annahmen hat, wie beispielsweise Datensparsamkeit ist etwas sehr Gutes und das ist es, was halt die Menschenwürde beschützt und auch die persönliche Freiheit, was ich halt so einfach finde, weil ich halt der Ansicht bin, einerseits, wie eben schon ausgeführt, dass durchaus die persönliche Freiheit von einer Verletzung der Datensparsamkeit profitieren kann und das halt durchaus ist eine Pflicht sogar vielleicht zur Datenmannigfaltigkeit geben kann, also im Sinne einer solidarischen Verantwortung, um halt die Gesellschaft zu Ich bin sehr froh, das zu verändern. Und das andere, seit ich auch Datenschutz halt sehr verdächtig finde in seinem Anspruch, jetzt irgendwie zu behaupten, ich schütze jetzt die Schwachen vor den Starken, weil ich nämlich den Eindruck hab, Datenschutz ist da durchaus in beide Seiten gebrauchbar. Das heißt, wir haben beispielsweise das Problem, dass Datenschutz halt dann den Polizisten schützt oder beispielsweise den wohlhabenden Steuer hinterziehe oder halt den Staat, der auf das Amtsgeheimnis pocht, während er sich relativ wenig darum schert, beispielsweise die Gängelung von Asylbewerbern, bei denen alles Mögliche an datenschutzrechtlichen Verletzungen oder halt bei Hartz-IV-Empfängern, bei denen sich nicht so sehr darum zu sorgen scheint. Das heißt, man kann durchaus auch sagen, Datenschutz kann durchaus dem Machtmissbrauch dienen, insofern er Strukturen stützt, die Machtmissbrauch begehen, insofern er sie beispielsweise der Transparenz entzieht, während er halt in anderen Fällen, in dem er Farm irgendwie einfordert von denen, denen es beispielsweise schlechter geht, die jetzt nicht ihr privates Elend ausbreiten sollen, indem er deren Äußerungen ihres Elends eigentlich der Öffentlichkeit entzieht.
Da haben wir aber dieses klassische Spannungsfeld wieder. Ich meine, der CCC hat ja schon immer dieser klassischen Hackerethik, den schönen Satz private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nützen, hinterhergeschoben und plädiert ja im Prinzip auch für eine klare Trennung eben des Privaten und des Öffentlichen. Nur ist es natürlich sehr schwierig, jetzt genau da den Regler an die richtige Stelle zu schieben, wo fängt das Private an, wo hört das auf und wo beginnt das Öffentliche und umgekehrt.
Ja, und das ist ja auch das Interessante. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel in die Öffentlichkeit, diese Idee der Öffentlichkeit vom anderen her denke, dann muss ich mich ja fragen, was hat diese andere vielleicht tatsächlich für ein vitales und durchaus berechtigtes Informationsinteresse an meinen Daten und zwar an meinen privaten Daten. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage, der andere ist halt ein Berufsanfänger in dem Feld, in dem ich mich auch betätige, dann hat er ein Interesse daran zu wissen, wie viel man dann in diesem Bereich lebt. Wir leben jetzt zum Beispiel in Deutschland in einer Gesellschaft, in der das absolute Tabu ist, über Geld zu reden. Über Geld spricht man nicht, das ist ja so ein bisschen so das Ding hier. Und das leistet natürlich Ausbeutung total Vorschub. Und es gibt unglaublich viele Unternehmen, die sehr gut von dieser Intransparenz leben, indem sie dem einen das bezahlen, dem anderen das. Und entsprechend Leute, die sich eben nicht trauen, in Gehaltsverhandlungen entsprechend aufzutreten. Und vielleicht, weil ihnen auch einfach das Hintergrundwissen fehlt, wie viel tatsächlich ihre Arbeit wert ist, halt dort auch nicht wirklich halt durchkommen. Das ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache. Oder zum Beispiel, wenn ich zum Beispiel meine Krankendaten, wir haben zum Beispiel auch ganz viel Paranoia, was die Krankendaten angeht. Das hat auch eine gewisse Berechtigung in Form von höhere Krankenkassensätze und so weiter und so fort.
Versicherungsrisiken.
Versicherungsrisiken etc. Aber andererseits...
Wer hat AIDS?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, dass alleine für die statistische, medizinische Beforschung ein unglaublicher Fortschritt da wäre, wenn tatsächlich zum Beispiel alle Krankenakten einer Datenbank verzeichnet wären. Es gibt natürlich auch noch persönliche Sachen. Also der andere kann halt wiederum auch der Arzt sein, der mich gerade nach einem Autounfall eine Blutfusion zukommen lassen will und der natürlich auch gerne auf Knopfdruck wissen will, welche Blutgruppe ich habe. Also diese der andere und seine Nicht-Definierbarkeit, das muss eben nicht nur der Fetischist sein oder der Nazi, sondern das ist eben ganz häufig auch tatsächlich derjenige, der ein vitales Interesse hat an meinen Daten und der eben vielleicht auch dadurch, wo ich dann sozusagen mit der Freigabe meiner Daten durchaus die Gesellschaft auch besser machen kann.
Da sprichst du natürlich jetzt einen interessanten Punkt an. Im Prinzip bewegen wir uns auch immer noch sozusagen in dieser politischen Diskussion des CCC, die seit langen führt, ohne dass ich jetzt hier das Ganze unter den, ja ich will jetzt hier nicht die CCC-Thesen überprüfen oder so. Das ist nur eine interessante Analogie, nämlich das Ding mit den Chancen und den Risiken, dass man eben, nicht wahr, der Baseballschläger, der sozusagen sowohl ein Sportwerkzeug sein kann, als eben auch ein Gewaltwerkzeug. Genauso kann eben jede Technologie in die eine oder andere Richtung angewendet werden. Und natürlich ist auch sozusagen jetzt diese Frage der Öffentlichkeit oder des Privaten, verstecke ich es oder mache ich es öffentlich, nutze ich es durch alle oder bleibt es im Verborgenen. Genauso eben Chancen und Risiken hatten, dass es letztendlich so eine Abwägungssache ist. Was mir dazu einfiel, ist, dass ich so ein bisschen die Vermutungen habe, dass so in unserem Kulturkreis auch so ein bisschen das Risiko eigentlich immer der Default ist. Dass man eigentlich immer erstmal so ein bisschen Angst hat. Wenn man zum Beispiel so sieht wie das Roboterbild, vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt, aber ich finde das immer sehr schön, wenn man sich anguckt, wie das so in Japan ist. Da wird so der Roboter generell und alle Firmen, die Roboter bauen, treten auch in der Öffentlichkeit immer so auf, so immer so als der Freund und Helfer und die Chance auf ein besseres Leben, weil uns die Roboter helfen können. Also der Roboter, das ist bei denen so primär so, ja der kann dann bei mir in der Wohnung sitzen und der kann irgendwie für mich abwaschen und das Fernsehprogramm für mich angucken und so weiter. Während wir hier so ein bisschen mehr so in dieser Frankenstein-Homunculus-Mentalität gefangen sind und die böse Maschine ja sobald auch nur irgendeine Fehlfunktion auftritt, mir gleich an die Google geht und mich irgendwie tötet. Also das scheint auch so ein bisschen so ein Default zu sein. Ist das irgendwie eine Kulturkrankheit, dass wir jetzt an der Stelle bei dem Datenschutz und der Privatsphäre-Diskussion häufig auch so von ja, aber bedenkt doch, was alles schiefgehen kann, ausgehen können, anstatt von dem bedenkt doch mal, was es Gutes bringen könnte für alle?
Ja, das hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen. Also letztens vor einer Woche oder so war ja Jeff Jarvis hier in Berlin und hat dort mit Tilo Weichert unter anderem diskutiert, also den Datenschützer aus Kiel. Und Jeff Jarvis ist ein amerikanischer intellektueller, so ein Web-intellektueller, würde ich mal so sagen, der so Journalist und der eben dieses Blog betreibt, Bassmaschinen und der jetzt eben auch gerade ein Buch darüber schreibt, also über The Value of Publicness nennt das, glaube ich. Und wobei, genau, und da hat er eben auch einen Vortrag schon gehalten auf der Republica mit dem German Paradox. Also er hat das tatsächlich auch ziemlich auf diese deutsche Diskussion und er sieht das durchaus auch genau und analysiert das als ein deutsches Phänomen. Und hat das auch eben auf diesem Podium so gesagt, dass er genau das so sieht, dass die Deutschen halt tatsächlich diese Chancen gar nicht so wahrnehmen wollen und sich immer nur auf die Risiken konzentrieren. Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt, das mag so sein, dass das in Deutschland ganz extrem ist und das sieht man ja auch an dieser Streetview-Debatte. Und wahrscheinlich werden wir im November dann eben auch eine Streetview haben, wo in jeder Straße irgendwo ein verpixeltes Haus ist. Und wahrscheinlich werden sich dann die ganzen Anspruchgegner auch alle den Arsch weg ärgern bzw. vielleicht werden dann die Leute dann auch ein bisschen gemobbt werden, so wie du hast unser Haus verpixeln lassen und so. Na jedenfalls, ich sehe aber das durchaus als so ein strukturelles Problem von Zukunftsfragen. Weil wenn du den Leuten sagst, hier passt mal auf, das und das, was ihr schon seit 20, 30, 40, seit eurem ganzen Leben lang kennt, das ist jetzt gerade in Gefahr. Dann haben die Leute etwas sehr, sehr Greifbares. Dann haben die Leute eine sehr, sehr konkrete Vorstellung, das was für sie irgendwie gerade wegbricht oder was in Gefahr ist. Wenn ich ihnen aber sage, schau doch, was vielleicht demnächst mal möglich ist mit Partizipation, mit Einmischung, mit öffentlichen Daten und dem Nutzen im Alltag und so weiter und so fort, dann sind das alles sehr, sehr abstrakte Theorien, abstrakte Dinge, die sie sich nicht so deutlich vorstellen können, wie das, was jetzt angeblich in Gefahr sein soll. Also ich glaube, solche Ängste vor dem Wegbruch von bestimmten Dingen sind durchaus kognitiv sehr viel leichter zu erfassen als irgendwelche Chancen, die immer sehr abstrakt bleiben.
Ich möchte eigentlich eine Lanze für die Sorge im Gegensatz zur Fangese brechen, weil ich durchaus finde, dass es legitim ist, sich um Sicherheiten zu sorgen, die einem wegbrechen. Ich glaube, selbst wenn man halt diese Position vertritt, dass wir eher vorsichtig sein sollten und eher nicht zu viel Vertrauen setzen sollten und irgendwelche Chancen, die sich auftun, mögen, wenn wir irgendwelche Sicherheiten aufgeben, dass man dann trotzdem nicht daran vorbeikommt, die bisherigen Sicherheiten in Frage zu stellen, weil mag sein, dass vielleicht es irgendwie ganz gut ist, der Status Quo und dass er viele Sicherheiten mit sich bringt. Aber wenn wir nun mal nicht verhindern können, dass diese Sicherheiten wegbrechen, müssen wir uns mit einer neuen Situation arrangieren. Und das Arrangement mit dieser neuen Situation, das würde meines Erachtens nicht funktionieren, wenn wir zu viel Vertrauen setzen in bisherige Konzepte wie Datenschutz beispielsweise oder dass wir tatsächlich irgendwelche Privatsphären in der Stabilität beibehalten können, wie wir das bisher getan haben. Ich glaube, wenn man zu viel Vertrauen darin setzt, dann wird man damit langfristig auf die Schnauze fliegen und sich damit eher fadeneinhandeln, als wenn man jetzt das Gegenteil täte. Das heißt, ich glaube, es gibt durchaus ein Argument pro Sicherheit, was darauf abzielt, wir müssen uns eigentlich mit den neuen Unsicherheiten arrangieren, wir müssen lernen, damit umzugehen, wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten, wir müssen Methoden entwickeln, mit beispielsweise der Ungewissheit umzugehen, was mit unseren Daten geschieht, wir müssen die Gesellschaft darauf vorbereiten, dass bestimmte ihrer Stabilität nicht mehr gegeben sind und dass sie die durch irgendwas anderes abpolstern muss, dass sie die Sachen, die bisher beispielsweise durch die Privatsphäre abgefangen worden sind, mit anderen abfangen muss und ich glaube, das ist dann ein Argument, was es eigentlich durchaus notwendig macht, solche Sachen wie Datenschutz zu überdenken, nicht nur, weil man dann irgendwelche fancy new Spielereien hat, sondern weil das eigentlich gerade verhindert Was hindert, dass man sich neu im Faden aussetzt?
Ja, genau. Das ist genau das. Ich hab das mal, wir haben so ein bisschen die Pflicht zur Utopie. Wir müssen jetzt gerade tatsächlich uns unter diesen neuen gegebenen Umständen überlegen, wie könnte dann eine Gesellschaft aussehen? Und wie müssen wir eine Gesellschaft gestalten, damit wir auch weiterhin trotz so einer Transparenz oder einer nicht kontrollierbaren Transparenz noch miteinander umgehen können, ohne uns dauernd an die Kehle zu springen oder wie auch immer? Was brauchen wir zum Beispiel für ein kulturelles Umdenken in Sachen Toleranz? Was brauchen wir aber auch zum Beispiel für eine neue Gesetzgebung, was zum Beispiel Persönlichkeitsrechte angeht? Was brauchen wir vielleicht auch tatsächlich für ökonomische Absicherung, wenn ich tatsächlich immer in irgendwelchen ökonomischen Abhängigkeiten von irgendwelchen anderen Leuten stehe? Ja, so konkrete Antworten nicht.
Das Grundeinkommen wird alle Probleme der Menfeite lösen.
Ja, das Grundeinkommen ist durchaus eine Sache, die ich da immer wieder anführe. Wenn wir zum Beispiel ein Grundeinkommen haben, dann haben wir in erster Linie ökonomische Unabhängigkeit des einen Individuums vom anderen. Und dann haben wir erst einmal nicht mehr diese Situation des Arbeitgebers, der sagt, dass sie sich jetzt bei den Piraten engagieren und dass sie jetzt dort irgendwo betrunken in der Ecke gelegen haben. Das ist jetzt für mich ein Kriterium, weswegen sie jetzt bei mir nicht anstehen können. Und das Individuum müsste dann um seine ökonomische Überlebensfähigkeit bangen. Dass wir jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Angst erstmal wegnehmen müssen, damit tatsächlich, ja, wir müssen, also ich sage immer, wir müssen die Kontrolle und die Macht des einen Individuums vom anderen, also diese Machtinstrumente müssen wir den Leuten aus der Hand nehmen. Die dürfen nicht mehr sich gegenseitig ihre Existenz bedrohen können.
Okay, ich meine, ich kann den Gedanken gut nachvollziehen, den können wir auch gerne nochmal verfolgen. Ich finde allerdings, der geht jetzt dann schon doch sehr weit weg von dem eigentlichen Thema, wo man jetzt überhaupt erstmal versucht, die privatsphäre Öffentlichkeit auszusortieren. Ich wollte nochmal kurz nachfragen, weil du das für einen angeführt hast, dieses Gespräch mit dem Javis und dem Tilo Weichert. Was kam denn da sozusagen bei Raus jetzt über seine generelle Feststellung, dass es da ein paar Radoks gibt bei den Deutschen?
Also was bei Tilo Raus kam, das war sehr, sehr witzig. Ich weiß nicht, ob er das aus Versehen gesagt hat, aber auf jeden Fall hat er, als es um Google ging und dass in Deutschland Google einen unglaublich hohen Marktanteil noch höher als in anderen Ländern, hat Google einen hohen Marktanteil an Suchen. Und jedenfalls hat Tilo Weichert in dem Moment irgendwo gesagt, wirklich alle Leute als dumm deklariert, die sind zu dumm, die eben Google benutzen und nicht irgendwelche datenschutzabgesicherten Suchmaschinen. Und da hat Jeff Davis natürlich sofort reingehauen, so ja klar, alle sind dumm. Und du musst den Leuten sagen, was die Leute zu tun haben. Und wer eben nicht Angst um seine Daten hat vor Google und so weiter und so fort, der ist einfach nur zu dumm, um das zu raffen und so. Und das spiegelt durchaus auch eine gewisse deutsche Mentalität, so eine deutsche Fingerhau und besserwisserische Mentalität wieder, die eben auch sozusagen genau den anderen immer vorschreiben möchte, was gut für sie ist. Also so ein bisschen so was Obrigkeitsmäßiges, was dann eben auch so ein Thilo Weichert in seiner Position dann durchaus durchscheinen lässt oder von der er sich hinreißen lässt. Also ich weiß besser, was gut für euch ist. Und wenn ihr eure Daten nicht versteckt, dann muss ich das jetzt für euch tun.
Dann werde ich jetzt mal versuchen, den Spiel so ein bisschen umzudrehen, vielleicht auch aus eurer eigenen Erfahrung heraus. Auch was so Medien wie Facebook betrifft. Wenn man jetzt mal versucht, das Positive zu sehen, ohne uns jetzt zu sehr mit Abwägungen aufzuhalten. Was ist denn so gut daran, dass ich auf Facebook kommuniziere? Was ist denn gut daran, dass ich mein Privates in die Öffentlichkeit ziehe?
Man wird aus der Isolation des Einzelnen hinausgelöst und hat plötzlich viele neue Anknüpfungspunkte. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwelche absonderlichen Interessen habe oder irgendwelche Meinungen, für die ich eigentlich keinen Rückhalt finde in meinem familiären Umfeld oder in meinem unmittelbaren sozialen Umfeld, soweit es mich räumlich umgibt, dann ist halt das sehr offene Umgehen mit eben diesen Eigenartigkeiten verleitet dann sehr schnell zum Finden von Anknüpfungspunkten bei anderen Leuten, die auch solche Eigenartigkeiten offensiv vertragen. Das heißt, mit denen kann ich mich dann leichter vernetzen. Mit denen kann ich dann leichter beispielsweise schlagkräftige Gruppen gewissermaßen bilden. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen der politische Nutzen. Anderer Nutzen, wie wir schon vorhin diskutiert haben, es baut halt gewisse, sagen wir mal, psychologische Einengungen ab. Im Sinne von, ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss mich für weniger Sachen schämen. Ich kann in gewisser Weise durchaus mehr für meine Eigenheit stehen, anstatt mich konformistisch verhalten zu müssen. Weil ich tatsächlich herausfinde, dass es halt sehr viele Menschen gibt, die auch diese Eigenheiten oder Probleme oder Schwächen haben. Und ich dann halt persönlich nicht mehr mich als jemand fühlen muss, dessen Privatproblem das ist. Im Sinne von, es ist ja mal meine eigene Schuld, dass ich meinetwegen die Steuererklärung nicht geschafft kriege, weil sie irgendwie zu kompliziert ist. Sondern ich sehe dann halt, viele Leute haben dieses Problem. Und ich muss es nicht mehr als mein eigenes Problem, an dem ich selbst mit mir selbst schuld bin, sehen. Sondern kann es als etwas sehen, was vielleicht einen größeren Druck von mehreren Menschen benötigt, um es zu verändern.
Also sie sind eigentlich eher im Bereich der Psychotherapie.
Ich glaube schon, dass wir ein bisschen abgerichtet sind auf die Autonomie des Individuums mit seiner vollen Selbstverantwortlichkeit. Was dann halt auch das Resultat hat, dass alles, was für uns ein Problem ist, schlussendlich in unserer Verantwortung liegen muss. Und dass wir dann halt nicht die Gesellschaft dafür beschuldigen können. Oder dass wir halt einfach dulden müssen, dass wenn wir so und so geboren sind, dann ist das halt unsere Sache. Und dann haben wir keinen Vergleichsmaßstab, der uns sagen könnte, es wäre beispielsweise anders.
Was du ja formulierst, ist ja ein Nutzen für das Individuum. Das ist sozusagen so, ich sollte öffentlich werden, weil ich dann irgendwie meine Schwächen dazu stehen kann. Genau, das ist sozusagen gut für mich. Aber ich muss sagen, meine Frage ist eigentlich eher, gibt es auch einen Nutzen für alle? Also gibt es einen gesellschaftlichen Nutzen daraus, dass eine Gesellschaft sich eben so einer Privatöffentlichkeit oder so eine Öffentlichkeitsprivaterie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es nennen soll, hingibt? Es gibt ja...
Ich würde sagen, was wir demokratische Öffentlichkeit nennen, würde sich durch so eine Gesellschaft, in der jeder mehr oder weniger eine öffentliche Person ist und sich für sich individuell spricht und miteinander vernetzt ist, würde sich zu einem organischen Diskurs, zu einer organischen Diskurs-Topologie entwickeln, die dann eben nicht mehr sozusagen über zentralistisch verschaltete Institutionen wie den Bundestag usw. sofort ihre politische Willensbildung kanalisieren muss, sondern die tatsächlich im Grunde genommen ihre Willensbildung leben kann in einem ständigen Diskurs. Und das ist durchaus, finde ich, eine sehr, sehr emanzipative Vision. Also das ist durchaus etwas, was ein totales Mehr an Demokratie wäre.
Ich glaube, man würde jetzt natürlich formulieren, naja, aber die Leute unterhalten sich ja nur darüber, was sie gerade im Fernsehen geschaut haben.
Aber das ist doch Quatsch, das ist doch genauso wichtig. Also, beziehungsweise, wer weiß, ich meine Fernsehen, also ich glaube jetzt nicht an die Zukunft des Fernsehens, aber sie werden sich wahrscheinlich durchaus über viele Katzenbilder auszutauschen. Und das ist ja auch richtig so. Und ich finde, dass es überhaupt nicht schlimm ist daran, sondern das ist, ich finde immer diese hochkulturalistische Perspektive auf die Gesellschaft, dass sie sich mit banalem Schund auseinandersetzt, finde ich immer so ein bisschen wohlfeil. Und ich finde, das gehört zu einem gesellschaftlichen Diskurs auch dazu, dass man sagt, das ist aber niedlicher als das. Und das ist aber noch niedlicher als das.
Aber wenn sich das jetzt alles so dezentral selbst organisiert und die Leute von sich aus herausfinden, was gut für sie ist und das untereinander vermitteln, ohne eine zentral vermittelnde Instanz, dann könnte man einwenden. Gut, dann werden halt die Leute, die beispielsweise besonders viel Selbstvertrauen haben, die besonders Safalobo sind beispielsweise, die werden sich dann auf diese Weise perfekt organisieren. Aber wir brauchen doch einen zentralistisch steuernden Staat, der das halt dann für die Leute regelt, die sich nicht so frei äußern können, die halt nicht das Selbstvertrauen aufbringen, die vielleicht nicht in dieser Weise erzogen sind. Also der Staat, der quasi weiter Macht hat, damit für die Schwächeren mitbestimmt werden kann, die nicht sich selbstständig äußern können.
Ja, also du, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mir gar nicht so eine wirklich ausgestaltete Vision und Utopie bisher geliefert. Und kann dir jetzt auch in den Einzelheiten gar nicht sagen. Ich glaube einfach allgemein, dass eine sich öffnende Gesellschaft, die miteinander viel mehr redet, und das passiert gerade durch das Internet, dass die durchaus einfach emanzipativer wird. Das merke ich einfach auch an mir, an mir selber tatsächlich eben, was ich meinte mit dem Krokodieren, dass ich mich ausleben kann und plötzlich Feedback bekomme, was du auch vorhin gesagt hast. Also dass ich mich ausdifferenzieren kann, und zwar in meine Neigung hin, und mich aber auch weiterentwickeln kann. Und ich glaube, ja, die Leute, die man vielleicht momentan noch in dieser Hinsicht schwach ausgebildet liegt, die haben halt auch noch lange ihre Potenziale in der Hinsicht noch gar nicht ausgeschöpft. Also ich bin da durchaus noch zuversichtlich und sehe da erst mal noch nicht. Das ist immer eine allgemeine Frage.
Aber auf jeden Fall, da muss auf jeden Fall irgendwas gefunden werden. Das Wesentliche an der Privatsphäre und am Datenschutz ist ja, dass sie halt Schutzräume halt doch bieten. Also man kann sich natürlich darüber streiten, ob sie nicht vielleicht auch Gefahrenräume faffen, durch Isolation und dergleichen. Aber das Wesentliche ist halt, dass sie viele Sachen duldbar machen, die nicht duldbar wären, wenn es so was wie die Privatsphäre nicht gäbe. Also eben beispielsweise, dass wir Menschen durchkategorisieren entsprechend ihres Verhaltens und sagen, jemand, der das und das getan hat, den finden wir nicht gut und der muss schlechter behandelt werden, beispielsweise. Das wird sehr viel duldbarer, wenn beispielsweise jetzt einen Raum gibt, wo ich mich verhalten kann, ohne dass es diesen äußeren Blick gibt, der mich beurteilt. Oder wenn es halt so etwas wie Vergesslichkeit gibt. Das heißt, was ja viel vom Datenschutz beispielsweise eingefordert wurde, dass es ein Verfallsdatum gibt für Wissen über Menschen. Und das Problem ist natürlich, sobald wir diesen Raum weg erodieren, müssen wir halt eigentlich auch versuchen, das weg zu erodieren, was nur durch diesen Raum duldbar wurde. Und daran liegt, denke ich, so eigentlich der politische Auftrag, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie groß hier über Privatsphäre und ihren Wegfall reden, dass herausgefunden wird, was können wir denn anstelle dessen setzen, was irgendwie die Gesellschaft weitererträglich macht.
Ja, ich hab letztens das mal getwittert. Eigentlich ist die wichtigste netzpolitische Forderung, Hartz IV muss weg. Aber das ist jetzt mal so nebenbei. Ja, so sehe ich wirklich so. Und da kommt man dann eben ganz schnell wieder raus aus diesem Diskurs und kommt dann eben zu dem Diskurs, wo der Diskurs ja eigentlich hingehört. Was sind die Probleme der Gesellschaft? Was sind die Vorurteile? Was sind die Leute, die Unterprivilegierten? Was sind die Mechanismen, die sie tatsächlich unterdrücken? Und dieser Datenschutzdiskurs ist teilweise tatsächlich ein Herumdoktern an nicht an den Ursachen der Probleme, sondern eben an Symptomen.
Das Problem mit dem Datenschutzdiskurs ist halt, dass er eben, das hatte ich ja vorhin schon angedeutet, sich beispielsweise nicht interessiert für die Probleme von Asylbewerbern. Da finden wir es ganz okay, dass bei den, oder bei HS4-Empfängern, da finden wir es ganz okay, dass bei denen alles Mögliche abgefragt wird. Und das ist ja auch, das ist sozusagen mit dem Rechtspositivismus des Datenschutzes auch vereinbart. Es ist einfach nicht Thema in den Datenschutz-Debatten, wie sie beispielsweise auf einer netzpolitischen Demo geführt werden.
Die letzte Demo, muss man dazu sagen, wurde das angesprochen.
Also, es ist mir beispielsweise aufgefallen, bei der Volkszählung, bei der Debatte zur Volkszählung, die jetzt letztens stattfand, worüber sich da aufgeregt wurde, dass beispielsweise Migrationshintergrund oder so abgefragt wird. Das sind alles unglaublich harmlose Daten, verglichen mit dem, was beispielsweise Hartz-IV-Empfänger den Ämtern mitteilen müssen. Oder was beispielsweise, wir haben da nämlich durchaus Fälle, sowohl bei Hartz-IV-Empfängern als auch bei Asylbewerbern, wo durchaus Daten sehr konkret als Mittel benutzt werden, um halt Leute bestimmten Gängelungen auszusetzen. Das heißt, wenn der Asylbewerber halt tatsächlich sagen würde, aus welchem Land er kommt, dann wird er halt abgeschoben. Während so etwas wie sich Aufregung über die Volkszählung oder was Google von mir weiß, das sind halt so relativ metaphysische Gefahren. Da könnte man mal durch Datenzusammenführung, könnte dann irgendjemand was über mich erfahren, was vielleicht irgendwie mir peinlich sein könnte. Das sind relativ harmlose Gefahren, verglichen zu mir werden Leistungen gestrichen oder ich werde abgeschoben. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass der Datenschutzdiskurs sich halt überproportional über diese eher metaphysischen Gefahren aufregt und relativ unterproportional über die Fälle, in denen tatsächlich auch tatsächlich im Rahmen des Gesetzes solche Daten erhoben werden, um dann halt tatsächlich auch Menschen halt konkreten Schaden zuzufügen.
Wobei ich jetzt niemanden unterstellen wollen würde, dass wenn man diesen Gesprächspunkt so aufbringt, dass dann alle da der Meinung sind, naja, aber Hartz IV wäre das ja alles okay.
Nee, aber das ist ein weniger Thema, das muss man schon nicht sagen. Also, wenn man sich die Datenschutzdebatten angeguckt hat, dann gab es immer ganz große Themen. Und auch heute gibt es noch ganz viele große Themen. Also die Angst vor der Wiedereinführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Elena und hast du nicht gesehen, ja, das sind alles, aber tatsächlich, genau wie Plomm sagt, das sind eigentlich alles so mehr oder weniger privilegierten Probleme. Und wenn man sich halt tatsächlich, und ehrlich gesagt, habe ich eine große Datenschutzdebatte im Zuge der Hartz-IV-Einführung vermisst, ehrlich gesagt. Also die war definitiv kleiner als zum Beispiel die jetzt für Elena ist, die das ja auch so ein Arbeitnehmer-Ding ist, ja, wo es ja, wo Arbeitnehmer sind ja heutzutage in unserer Gesellschaft schon privilegierte, ja. Und also das ist definitiv lauter, also durchaus um einen mehrfachen Faktor.
Ich glaube, dass das liegt halt auch so ein bisschen daran, dass Datenschutz sich sehr, inzwischen sehr staatsfreundlich halt gibt. Das heißt, es ist halt weniger ein, wir sind jetzt irgendwie anarchische Paranoide, die Angst vor allem haben, was der Staat macht, sondern wir pochen eigentlich darauf, dass der Staat uns Datenschutz gibt. Wir machen uns Begriffe zu eigen, die die Gerichte beispielsweise prägen, wie beispielsweise die informationelle Selbstbestimmung und vertrauen darauf, dass diese uns Schutz geben gegenüber anderen. In Fällen allerdings, wie beispielsweise bei Hartz IV oder bei Asylbewerbern, da ist ja durchaus gesetzlich geregelt, was passiert und was zu welchen Zwecken gesammelt wird. Und es ist auch gar nicht ungesetzlich, dass über den Hartz IV-Empfänger das und das eine Erfahrung gebracht wird, oder dass über den Asylbewerber das und das ausgehorcht wird, sondern es dient einfach schlicht und einfach der Durchsetzung des Gesetzes. Während die vielen Sorgen, die Datenschutz üblicherweise thematisiert mehr sind, ja, man könnte ja die Daten dann theoretisch zusammenführen, auch ungesetzlich beispielsweise, und wir müssen einfach nur eine gesetzliche Regelung schaffen, die diese und jene Datenauswertung oder Datenzusammenführung illegal macht, und dann ist das Problem mehr oder weniger gelöst.
Ja, was ist denn, also jetzt habt ihr auch schon viel irgendwie die Utopie angesprochen, so ich meine, ich erwarte jetzt nicht von euch, dass ihr da alle Antworten habt. Trotzdem ist das natürlich schon, dass ein bisschen was hinter dieser ganzen Debatte steht. Und ich habe auch so die Eindruck, diese Debatte hat eigentlich erst so richtig begonnen. Es ist irgendwie so ein, viel wird mit pauschalen Argumentationen, wenn nicht sogar Nicht-Argumentationen gemacht, so die Privatsphäre muss geschützt werden, ohne dass klar ist, wo sie anfängt, wo sie aufhört. Datenschutz ist wichtig, ohne genau zu definieren, was eigentlich dazu gehört. Und ich glaube auch nicht unbedingt, dass wir immer alle einer Meinung sind. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt auch schon klargemacht, sehr wohl gibt es Bereiche, wo all das seine Berechtigung hat. Die Privatsphäre hat selbstverständlich ihre Berechtigung, Datenschutz hat irgendwie seine Berechtigung. Andererseits merken wir auch, es gibt einen de facto Umgang mit Daten, der sich nicht mehr einfach in dieses, ich bestimme alles selbst hineinzwängen lasse, allein schon, weil es nicht mehr möglich ist, alles selbst zu bestimmen. Man wird irgendwie fremdbestimmt, Kontrollverlust, wie du das genannt hast, was sicherlich ein ganz treffender Aspekt drin ist. Aber es gibt eben auch eine politische Dimension dieser neuen Öffentlichkeit, von der man sozusagen möchte, dass Leute ihn eigentlich auch ausüben, dass jeder sozusagen mehr öffentlich wird, als er es bisher vielleicht war, um eben eine demokratische Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen, die jenseits der Katzenbilder sich eben auch tatsächlich über diese Inhalte, die uns alle betreffen, auch austauscht. Fasse ich so ein bisschen den Scope unseres Gesprächs der letzten zwei Stunden, umkreise ich das gut? Oder seht ihr noch eine andere Richtung, die man hier noch bedenken müsste, um einfach mal das Spannungsfeld auch abzustecken, um dann mal zur Utopie zu kommen? Was ich mich frage jetzt ist sozusagen, wie seh eine freiregie Gesellschaft ohne Privatsphäre aus? Wo geht es hin? Was ist sozusagen die Vision?
Also was ich ganz spannend fände, ist ja tatsächlich, wenn es diese größere informationelle Integration gibt, wo tatsächlich jeder Punkt im Gesellschaftsgebilde sehr viel mehr weiß über alles, dass das ja durchaus einen neuen gesellschaftlichen Intelligenzgrad produziert. Wir können eher sehen, wo Probleme sind, wo Potenziale sind und dergleichen. Und das wiederum, denke ich, ist nützlich. Also beispielsweise, was MS. Prophorin meinte, es ist nützlich zu wissen, wie die Volksgesundheit gewissermaßen statistisch beschaffen ist, wo sich beispielsweise Krankheitsmuster bilden, welche Methoden beispielsweise bei Krankheiten scheinbar besser greifen als andere Krankheiten. Das sind ja Sachen, die dann konkreten Nutzen haben, weil wir beispielsweise eher wissen, wir können die Medikamente einsetzen als andere Medikamente und die werden eher positive Ergebnisse produzieren. Und ich glaube, das trifft auf viele Bereiche zu, dass wir halt das gesellschaftliche Gehirn insgesamt informierter wird und mehr tun kann, mehr größere Handlungsfreiheit hat, um bestimmte Ziele beispielsweise zu erreichen, wie meinetwegen die Verbesserung der Gesundheit, eine bessere Verteilung oder sagen wir mal Sicherung von sozialen Grundbedürfnissen und dergleichen. Also was ich damit eigentlich nur sagen wollte, es steigert halt die Entwicklung des Weltgehirns ganz Singularity-mäßig.
Also ich bin halt selber für mich noch gar nicht so richtig durch mit diesem Begriff des Anderen, weil da steckt noch eine ganze Menge drin. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt sagst, wir werden zu einem Weltgehirn und die Gesellschaft wird informiert über sich selbst, dann ist das immer noch irgendwie herausgedacht aus einem monolithischen Verständnis von Gesellschaft. Aber ich glaube, man muss schon den Einzelnen betrachten. Also der Einzelne, der wird nicht, auch wenn die gesamte Gesellschaft transparent ist, in einem großen Panorama auf ihn einströmen, sondern dort haben wir eben dieses Paradigma der Abfrage. Das ist ja der Witz. Wie öffentlich ist das, wenn irgendwo steht, dass Tim Pritlove schwul ist oder so etwas? Dann ist das zwar egal, ob da jetzt zwei Leute auf diese Webseite kommen, sondern es ist von entscheidender Bedeutung, dass jemand in sein Suchfeld Tim Pritlove eingibt und dann auf diese Seite gelangt. Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, was öffentlich ist, also dieses Konzept von Öffentlichkeit, das tatsächlich ein Stufenkonzept ist von etwas ist mehr oder etwas ist weniger öffentlich, je mehr Leute darauf schauen und darauf einen Blick haben, wird abgelöst von einem Öffentlichkeitsbegriff, der von einem Unbekannten, aber einer Einzelperson, die eine konkrete Anfrage hat, abgelöst. Und dieses Denkmodell, das ist noch gar nicht so richtig begriffen, weil tatsächlich wird es ja sicher auch so gefühlt, so ja, irgendjemand auf einem Blog, den zwei Leute im Jahr lesen, hat irgendwas über mich geschrieben, ist aber egalrelevant. Es ist trotzdem eben sozusagen für den einen anderen, diesen Unbekannten, der dann irgendwann mich googeln wird, ist es eben öffentlich. Und ich glaube auch, wenn wir, das heißt also mit anderen Worten, es ist ja keine insgesamt informiertere Gesellschaft, sondern wir haben eben zwar Zugriff, jeder hat Zugriff zu allen Informationen, aber wird eben alleine aus seiner ganzen Lebenszeit gar nicht es schaffen, wenn alle Informationen überhaupt einmal angesehen zu haben. Wir haben ja dann, man muss das dazu sagen, das ist ja auch ein Wust an mehr Informationen, diese Menge an Informationen.
Wir wissen gar nicht, welche davon wahr sind und welche falsch.
Ja, das auch noch, ja, das kommt ja dazu. Also das heißt mit anderen Worten, das wird unglaublich schwierig, halt da eine konkrete Vision draus zu entwickeln, weil es so ein komplexer Prozess ist und eigentlich alle Ideen und alle Vorstellungen von Öffentlichkeit und Gesellschaft negiert im Grunde genommen.
Eine futuristische Utopie habe ich noch und zwar die fließt an, was du gesagt hast mit der historischen, quasi mit dem Historikerinteresse an dem, was haben wir denn alles an Daten, was können wir denn dann daraus beispielsweise an Realität festhalten und dann wieder aufbauen. Ich denke nämlich tatsächlich, dass je mehr wir von uns halt in Medien externalisieren und halt auch stabil und portabel machen, indem wir halt uns nicht so sehr darauf pochen, dass das nur auf beispielsweise meiner privaten Festplatte liegt, sondern sich halt durchs Netz verbreitet und dann dort ein Eigenleben entwickeln kann, dass das tatsächlich dazu beiträgt, dass halt je mehr Daten über jemanden im Umlauf sind, dessen Person oder zumindest sagen wir mal dessen Informationsmatrix umso mehr halt ein Eigenleben entwickeln kann von der Sterblichkeit seiner körperlichen Hülle. Das heißt, dass halt Historiker sehr viel besser dann, beispielsweise künftige Holodecksimulationen dich simulieren können, wenn dein ganzes Privatleben in Form einer Biografie dokumentiert ist, als wenn über dich nur ein Eintrag in irgendeiner Chronologie ist, dass er dann geboren und dann gestorben ist.
Ja, das ist genau das, ja, das ist sozusagen die Langzeitvision des Kontrollverlusts, ja. Also die, die tatsächlich Mind-Upload, der ja tatsächlich ja jetzt schon mehr oder weniger passiert. Und das ist ja auch der Witz, also wenn man das jetzt wirklich ganz weit und ganz wild spinnt, ja dann kann man jetzt eigentlich, selbst wenn wir jetzt noch sterben, ja, werden uns vielleicht, haben wir vielleicht jetzt schon genug Daten in die Welt geblasen, dass zukünftige Algorithmen, die in 50 Jahren erfunden oder 100 Jahren erfunden werden, denen das schon ausreicht, um uns halt hinreichend gut zu simulieren.
Also Post-Privacy als Selbstbehauptung.
Ja.
Da haben wir die besten Voraussetzungen hier bei Chaosradio Express, weil die Sendung wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Und ich bin gespannt, was dabei rauskommt, auch wenn wir vielleicht selber nicht mehr an den Ergebnissen zu teilhaben werden. Zum Thema Kontrollverlust kann ich nur sagen, jetzt werden wir hier gerade von den Bauarbeiten kräftig ins Korn genommen. Aber ich würde auch gerne die Diskussion jetzt an der Stelle abschließen und auch bewusst offen lassen, weil das Ganze eh nur so als Gedankenanregung angedacht war. Als solche glaube ich auch ganz gut funktioniert. Die Frage des Verhältnisses zwischen Privatsphäre, Datenschutz, Öffentlichkeit und welcher Vision es so für demokratische Öffentlichkeit gibt, die steht im Raum und muss weiter analysiert werden. Insofern vielen Dank, Plomm und MSPro, die Angestellte eurer Nicknames mal versteckt und mal nicht. Inmitten der Privatsphäre von Chaosradio Express.
Das hört hier eh keiner an.
Auf jeden Fall sind wir nur unter uns. Das ist schon mal gesichert. Und die Bohrer da draußen. Ich hoffe, dass sie nicht so sehr auf der Aufnahme gelandet sind. Wir werden es sehen. Ihr werdet es hören bei der nächsten Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.